The music is killing me.
The birds.
Peppeloni.
How am I supposed to prepare for your live if you do not tweet in one hour?
Sorry!
It's because I...
This is a lie that keeps receiving...
I was busy today and I forgot to make a waiting room and then I forgot to...
Well, I made the waiting room and then I forgot to...
Uh, tweet in one hour.
Oopsie!
I...
You always were a kid or me too.
But moment.
Bye bye.
um what was i doing today oh i was um it was time it's time it was time it's time it was time because i changed out my summer clothes with my winter clothes so that's what i was doing i was taking everything out of my closet and putting it away and then and then taking everything out of boxes and putting it up and that's what i did winter is not quite here fall is here but it's the same thing happy spooky week hope you got your candy i haven't wait
i haven't
hmm Cold equals the same.
That's a problem.
That's a big problem.
Actually, I have some candy.
Hold on.
I met a friend from the Yokei, and she gave me some chocolate.
Cadbury dairy milk buttons.
Orange flavor.
and they're really good I've been trying not to eat all of them immediately I mean I've had them for over a month now but still not over a month oh wait maybe yeah they are so yummy though Cadbury buttons are always peak are there other flavors I like the orange I like orange chocolate so I'm a big fan of this.
Hey, peace!
Welcome back to membership.
Thank you.
Um, do we know this British friend?
No.
It's not Vicky.
Who else do I know that's British?
Limu, no.
I was supposed to meet Limu this weekend, actually.
I was...
Erb, no.
it's not a vtuber it's not a vtuber it's but it's a my friend is is is normal she's normal
but um do you know what days you'll appear in holiday maturi i'm only going for one day but i want to make it to your meet and greet oh we haven't decided a meet and greet day yet or days i don't know honestly how many i'm doing i think i will be at the con every day or at least doing something at the convention every day so friday i have something and saturday i have something and then i have panels panel panels i don't remember and meet and greet unfortunately i can't tell you schedule just yet though sorry um but yeah what was Oh yeah,
any other button flavors?
I'm so curious.
Was it the ghost of the queen?
Oh my gosh.
Stop lying, Minky.
All British people are VTubers.
I don't know about that.
We would have more EU streamers then, right?
Oh, Limu.
Yeah, I was supposed to meet Limu this weekend.
At least that was like the plan.
I don't know if she knows that or not.
So don't be going to live movie and like hey what happened with your plans with me though i think i kind of decided is
that like caramel and milk but um this weekend uh was i was going to be going to the uk to go see metal gear and concert i was so excited i was really excited but i was like i'm then then some other things happened started popping up in November and I was like,
I can't travel anymore because I'm already traveling so much in November so I decided against it and so then I could I could be here and also, you know, US Idol Festival and everything
but yeah you should have gone I feel like it was way too much time that i was not streaming so hopefully hopefully the concert decides to come to the us then i can go to that
ended up falling asleep last night after all good i had spooky dreams good also there are mint flavored chocolate buttons they're not bad hmm i think though i don't know if i would like them more than the orange, I'll be honest.
Welcome back to Membership Sanku!
I love my noodle arms.
Oh, you love...
Wait, I love your noodle arms.
Is this a code?
Why is...
Why are there spaces?
Okay.
but yeah so maybe one day i will go to the great city of london and go to that shrek land and oh what's the ferris wheel called maybe one day i will okay i feel like though if i go to europe for the first time i want to go to austria first so that i can go see kiwawa but The London Eye.
So creepy.
Yeah.
Yeah, I gotta go to Australia.
Got to see Fleet Street?
The daemon Bob were on Fleet Street.
Kiwawa might drag you to Maldives?
Maldives?
Is that how you pronounce it?
Hmm.
Oh yeah, you know.
Obviously, I'm trying not to plan so much travel right now, though, because my upcoming months are kind of insane, so...
My upcoming months are kind of insane.
Some of it having to do with checking out places for me and moving.
So...
Yes!
Yeah!
One day, one day I'll move.
One day I'll move.
Get out of my moldy mid-cafe.
And find a new mid-cafe, the haunt.
Yeah, lots have been going on behind the scenes.
A lot has been going, actually so much has been going on behind the scenes!
I hope that you guys can look forward to a lot of the stuff that has been cooking.
in the background that will all be revealed eventually.
But today we play more Harvester,
which, does anybody know what's going on in this game?
I don't know if I will be able to beat the game today, but I would like to try.
I do have some stuff I need to do tonight.
11 p.m.
EST.
So, I have until then.
I'm happy that you're finally working on moving.
It's definitely more healthy for you.
Thank you!
Yeah!
So, what?
Okay, let's see.
I like these, these kind of...
The way that I...
Name these.
I like we have chapter 10, Jimmy James.
chapter 11 death of jimmy james what does scratch mean i don't know why did i manhole okay i get oh this was scratching the car i think um like bees okay that was the hornet lady i get that application okay the application to the to the lodge get pranked wait scratch Thank you for that gift and I've never seen anybody change their profile picture more than you.
Your save game names are almost as nonsensical as Joel's were in his playthrough years back.
Maybe because you have to be a little nonsensical to play this.
Pepperoni though.
Why did I name it pepperoni?
Why didn't I have a pepperoni?
I think it was, probably, if I had to guess.
Probably because of his nipples.
Oh, sorry, my bud.
What I want to, like I said, I want to probably try and beat the game today.
I do have a guide up.
So, not salami.
I was warned.
I think we're on day three, though, so we have quite a bit to get through.
We have quite a bit to get through.
Sorry, me.
Oh my gosh, you did it again!
If you do visit Austria and then you somehow end up ever touring Eastern Europe, end up in Prague, you could always recreate emptiness for Hax-3.
That's so specific.
That's like the most specific catch moment ever.
Ah, yes.
I'll walk down the streets.
I can't whistle.
Yeah, I'll do that while stalking Kiara.
Wait, no.
She would have to whistle.
Thanks again for my first watching on the cover of the Garibald.
Thank you for hanging out with us.
Thank you.
Milky, welcome back to Angu.
Europe.
Hope you decide to come to Ireland at some point.
We have sheep and cows, among other things.
Wow, I like all those things.
I want to go.
All right, so yeah, I have my walkthrough.
Let's just get into it.
I have six hours to beat this game.
A little less than.
Right?
Yeah.
Let's try...
Oh, wait.
Pepelone.
Let's hit it.
Okay, we just woke up.
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to think.
We scratched that guy's car.
But I don't know where we go from here.
Ireland might mention?
Yeah.
I don't know what we do here.
To the lodge?
Look at that baby.
Examine the baby.
A newborn baby is sleeping soundly.
Okay, let's go to the lodge then.
We also killed Jimmy James.
We're so good.
Let's go to the lodge.
Wait, I thought we already told the guy that we scratched his car.
Oh, you have completed your first task now that you've scratched.
Yeah.
You may proceed to your second task Okay, you will steal a bolt of fabric from the fireman.
Oh The fireman Oh, that's right.
I I said like all the okay.
I remember him saying this Okay, I'll do it very well then use whatever means necessary but bring the cloth to a healer task.
Okay.
All right, hold on.
I'm going to look a little bit at the walkthrough.
Reward money.
Did we get reward money?
What?
Oh, wait.
No, we're on day three.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Sorry, I was reading day four.
My bad.
Okay.
All right.
So we got our new task.
Um, we're on day three.
Let's go to the fire station.
Hi.
Sorry, Steve.
After I'm through here, I've got cleaning to do.
Rush, rush.
I love the fire department.
Why do we sometimes hear like a dog getting slapped?
I don't like that.
Saliva is foaming from his barking chops.
on the alien music wait I forgot about it this game is so oh my god sparky hey queen hello Steve lovely day isn't it still sketching the same nude man I see it doesn't behoove one to be fickle besides once you find a perfect model you don't let him go go Fabric.
What kind of fabric are we trying to get?
Come again?
Okay, it doesn't know what I'm talking about.
Bye-bye.
I don't converse on the job, Steve.
What's the mural?
Oh, a photorealistic mural of a peaceful countryside.
This is not a window!
Oh my gosh, I feel like I've been bamboozled.
This is...
place an accident just waiting to happen i mean you could say that about any fireplace what's wrong with this one yeah there's light coming in how is this a mural wait what can you pet the dog no i like that the dog has been like fmv recorded too it's so good also this guy is doing like Harry Potter spells.
He's not touching the canvas at all.
He's like, a light brush here, a light brush there.
Wingardium Levio song.
I, what?
Okay, freaking me out.
Get me out of here.
What's our name again?
Steve?
was it Steve okay I'm just gonna consult because we're starting a little bit in the middle I'm going to consult the what's it called the guide a little bit we did go to the cemetery apparently we need to go back here we need to come back here and we gotta examine this yet another resting place amongst the graves operate aha is where he was digging yesterday,
like, I say yesterday, but last time.
Why are they drawing some dude at the fire department, though?
Because they're, they're passing the time until they need to do anything.
Padded shovel marks are visible on this fresh dirt mound.
Do I examine it?
Uh, do I not have a shovel?
Oh my Gosh, the lightning is, or thunder is crazy.
Do we have a shovel?
Did I miss getting that?
I thought I...
Wait, I don't remember how to use items.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, hold on.
Now, well, thank you so much for the time to get done.
I'm turning it down just a little bit.
Wait.
Inventory.
Okay, here we go.
Ah, okay, okay.
Right click to...
There we go, okay, okay.
You shovel.
Ah!
Hello, Karen!
Good morning!
Thank God I found you.
Are you alright, Karen?
I want to go home.
Could you take me to my mommy's store or to the policeman?
Can you tell me who did this to you?
Mr. Potstan told me he'd hurt.
my mommy if i told oh well i think we know now who did it tell me what happened he made me play house then he dug a hole please i just want to go home now please can you tell me your address honey i don't know just take me to the store or the policeman please mommy said to go to the I think this is more than a boss,
Karen.
Bye-bye.
Okay.
We'll go to...
Karen scurries off ahead of you.
Come on, Karen.
I'm taking you to your mom's place.
Bye-bye.
Uh, Edna's diner.
We made it.
Bye-bye.
What?
Oh my god.
Karen.
Thank god.
What happened?
Found her in the graveyard.
She was buried alive.
He's so serious about it, but no one else is, it feels like.
Thank you, Steve.
Thank you from both of us.
Here.
Here's the reward money.
Take it to go.
The reward money.
I need to be alone with my baby right now.
What do you mean the reward money?
As if there was a...
As if we knew that she was...
I guess
we got money.
How much money we get?
This is a note.
How much money do I have?
Oh, reward money!
Let's go.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
That's right.
Right click is, like, punching and...
When am I going to start being able to kill things, I wonder?
Okay.
Interesting.
Okay, um, all right, hold on.
Get me out of here.
It says we go to the memorial.
What was the beginning?
Oh, that's, uh, the school, right?
Yeah.
So we're gonna use the fire alarm here.
Four more magazines!
Oh, yeah.
Oh, hello.
you hear again one would think you'd never graduated nostalgia is a waste of time big guy you need to move forward and if you ask me the lodge lights firmly in that direction mr johnson says one of my pupils scratched his priceless tucker i must say i was relieved when i learned he had no evidence pointing to one of my kids if he had some lucky boy or girl would I hate the words.
Congratulations on finding Karen Fitzpatrick.
Oh, thank you.
Don't know how you did it, but if I was still publishing the Sentinel, you can bet I'd run a full profile on you.
Wait, I've just realized I scratched the car with my key.
Would there not be evidence of that then, maybe?
Okay, bye.
Alright, so what we're gonna...
Drop in again soon.
You told me not to.
Adult education is a wonderful thing.
thing as is a dope quality tie the fire alarm okay so what we can do is we pull the fire alarm and that will get the fire department people to leave right
quality time i can't take this game seriously even like a tiny it.
What's that?
Fire axe.
Propped on its side in the back of the garage is a fire axe.
I'll take that.
Yoink.
And, uh, what's this?
A ladder.
Yoink.
What else is in here?
Nothing.
Okay, cool.
Um, are they gone?
Oh, I can't even go inside.
Wait, what did I just... Oh, the fence.
Okay.
Uh, wait, what?
How am I supposed to get and steal their thing?
Oh my god, stop hitting the dog!
Yeah, where's the bolt of cloth?
Flowers.
With all the rose...
With all the rose pretty flowers, the firemen must have a ton of time on their hands.
Fire truck It's pink You guys will never let me live that down Um Okay Well I'm gonna leave here then If that's all I guess It's pink I rewatch that clip a lot Oh Hello, welcome to Bamboo Shift.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, I was just kidding.
I'm a kidder, you guys.
I'm a kidder.
Okay.
I don't want to go to the meat plant.
Okay, people before stream told me about the meat plant.
And so I have a little censor.
I will censor it for you guys.
Unfortunately, I will still unfortunately be able to see it.
But...
Uh...
You guys will...
It'll be censored for you guys, so it won't be so cool.
gross.
Do I have to go here?
Yet?
I mean... I don't know what else to do.
Okay, I'm looking at the...
I'm gonna... I'm looking at the walkthrough, you guys.
Go home.
Use the furniture dolly on the living room shelves.
There's an alarm.
What?
How am I supposed to know that?
Wait, what if I got the frisbee down?
Damn it.
Oh, man.
Okay, it was worth a try.
Okay, so I use it...
I use the furniture dolly.
What furniture dolly?
On the living room shelves.
there's shelves in here besides the cabinet am I crazy I have the dolly do I oh whoops do I man whole kid shovel pitchfork what is this screwdriver I don't have no dolly we're next to the ladder oh I do have wait use it on the shell okay
how would you know to do this what huh turn the alarm off and go outside
you turn off the alarm system weeks of fun weeks of fun what how are you supposed to know that and then you use oh oh I never noticed these bars.
There are security bars fast into the window.
I'm supposed to know how to figure it out by spending koality.
It's my birthday.
Marseille, happy birthday!
Celebrated by bringing my pleasure to you everywhere and eating yummy treats!
That's the best way!
Let's celebrate!
There's a little gift for me for making my year brighter.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Thanks for including...
Oh, my bad.
Thanks for including me.
Sorry, I did something that you guys...
I used the wrong mouse.
Okay, so now we use the Phillips screwdriver on this guy.
You dismantle...
Ooh, what a terrible sound.
You dismantle the bars from the window with the screwdriver.
And we go talk to her dad?
Oh!
I don't think I need to censor anything at the moment.
It's just a...
Ah!
Has this been in here the whole time?
Wait, where is... Oh, Dad is just in bed.
Why are the walls covered in blood?
Wait, if I examine the picture, will I get...
Hold on.
I will censor real quick.
Oh, okay.
I thought I would like zoom in, you know?
A screenshot from the movie Rosie Palm meets Rosie cheeks.
So that's your dad, now I know why you are such a freak.
Classic film, classic film.
I mean, those are some prosy cheeks.
Mom's a hello kitty girl, apparently.
What does that mean?
I'm examining the sex toys.
Exotic, kinky love equipment.
No, leave that there.
If any of it turns out missing.
Marv, what's going on in there?
Oh,
go!
Don't talk!
I'm just standing here.
What's this?
This photograph is a constant torture for poor old dad.
What does that mean?
No.
No, no!
Oh.
Marv, what's going on in there?
Go.
No!
Shh!
Stop talking!
Okay, I can't examine the sex toys or else...
Oh my god, they're everywhere.
At least she gave him a fan.
I can barely...
I can barely see he's there because he's wrapped in bandages.
Oh my gosh, there's even chains on the ceiling!
This is...
This is a torture chamber!
Um, hi dad.
Steve.
Is that you?
to see her pearl dead are you my father really i don't remember are you my father i'm not in the mood for jokes i'm serious why won't anyone believe me well you always were a kid or steve just don't make me laugh now remember the stitches my god what has she done to you she doesn't know you're here does she does she my dad's a mummy No,
I had to break it.
What the hell is going on in here?
The sudden cutscene.
I know it's a mystery to you.
The sacred things that husbands and wives do behind closed doors.
Maybe we should have that special father-son talk.
Especially now that you're getting married.
Is this gonna happen to Steve?
Yeah, I'd like that.
Then listen.
I can't talk very loud it's the tracheotomy tracheotomy what is that something with his throat oh love each other very much they go into a room alone and shut the door and bolt it with at least three locks and prop a chair under the doorknob so no one can get in throat surgery or out Then they take off their clothes and get out a wide variety of scalpels.
Some curved, some short, all of them sharp.
And then the man climbs on the woman.
And then they...
With the barbed wire.
Barbed wire!
Where did that come in?
That's all right.
don't get worked up you need your rest yes what's going on in harvest town but why did you come guys don't get married must have had a reason or do risking it no i just wanted to see how you're doing so i'd i'd like to talk to you there was something terrible i wanted to warn you about but i can't think of it now still you've got to go before she catches us go now and quickly
going on in there never got the talk yeah me neither actually go go stop yelling what
oh wait okay wait hold on we need to to do this real quick uh i forgot about this i sorry i looked at the walkthrough um there was wasn't there something that needed to get signed or am i crazy
Wait, what is this?
No, not this.
Save?
Yeah.
Um.
Marriage.
Save.
Slip from the meat factory.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought I...
I thought I had something.
No?
Do I need to go to the factory and get it, maybe?
I thought I remember hearing...
Maybe I'm thinking of a different thing that needed to get signed.
Mewage.
Open the door.
It won't let me...
Wait.
Yeah, it won't let me actually.
Okay, I think I need to go to...
Under the bat?
Unless?
No, that's just a note.
Yeah, I think maybe I have to go...
To the meat plant.
Sorry, I'm like following a walkthrough now, but I wasn't last stream, so I'm a little discombobulated.
Alright, guys.
I don't want to be here.
This is me.
Okay, apparently it's like the bottom right that is like not good.
So, um, we'll do our best.
We'll do our best here.
I'm just gonna go in.
And then...
Yeah, this game is discombobulated.
I'm just gonna go in and hopefully it's censored hopefully okay it's censored oh gosh I'm gonna talk to this guy Steve how's your father is he better uh about the same I guess he's been away from work for weeks and when I call your house your mother won't let me talk to him believe me he's a hard man to see right now this is a fine kettle of fish I must say fish i am glad to see you taking an interest in the business in your dad's absence who are you oh steve i didn't want to believe that amnesia hookham now you're saying you don't remember your pal pat o'reilly okay um i don't i'm not gonna ask about the cats looks like they had some quality time you may come to realize that this business is not for everybody just ask your poor ill dad.
It takes dedication and a strong stomach.
Ah!
What the hell was that?
A lot of times, when I'm finished scrubbing up and digging the bits of intestine out from my fingernails, I must confess I don't have much appetite for red meat.
That's so fair.
But red meat is one of the principal food groups, and you got to have it.
So when you can do this all day and help yourself to a juicy red steak afterwards, then by golly, you can call yourself a butcher.
of course amnesia would certainly help that wouldn't it um dad's illness what exactly is wrong with you that's a great question i can't get in to see him he's all cut up lying in bed broken man and i think she did it to him who my so-called mother shame on you trying into what goes on in the sanctity of your parents bedroom you're young you don't a man of the world running the family business a member in good standing of the lodge you'll understand the beauty of what transpires between husbands and wives am i just not an adult do i just not understand the family business you may come to realize that this husband and wife is it because i've never been married i don't understand your dad it takes dedication oh wait i think i did oh oh it doesn't even look like anything a lot of times when i'm finished okay thank you Thank you.
Oh, oh gosh.
I meant to press the... I should have pressed the lodge instead.
Of course, Amni.
Uh...
Meat?
Come to think of it.
I don't see any cattle around here.
I'm scared to ask this.
Does it matter?
The end product is all the customer cares about, Steve.
You'll get it when you grow up, Minto?
Only the juiciest guy.
once you take over the business you realize oh my god no not again please i've seen it enough would the lodge use us to cater their affairs um oh god not the lodge again i'm sure it's good but i have some meat to take home oh your father's very particular about okay here we go no freebies for anyone but seeing how you're here we go here we go here we go written permission from your father i'll give you the meat give me the meat the law Oh wait,
so do I did I get the thing for the order of the harvest moon sponsors a weenie roast on the lodge grounds every summer I wonder why heck the best way to find out is to sign up with them They're a great organization Steve.
That's what happens when we miss out on the talk They do what needs to be done and expect nothing in return then how do they support themselves Membership dues from what I hear the work is its own reward Okay, bye.
Don't be such a stranger, Steve.
And my best to your dad.
All right, hold on.
Let me see if we got the thing that we...
Ah!
Meat permission slip!
Okay, we got it.
We can go.
I don't...
I'm scared to see if I could like...
Examine the barrels.
Whatever is in these barrels smells extremely bad.
Okay, I can't examine any of the cats.
Oh gosh.
Examine the splotch?
Examine the meat!
I don't want to.
Let's get out of here.
Go, go, go.
Let's go to Papa.
And then we go back into the meat room.
Poor little babies.
Hello, father.
Why is there a hole in his neck?
I need some meat.
And Pat won't give me any without your signed permission.
Steve needs some meat huh here son here's my signature take it to him and you won't have any problem now go son go quickly before she comes back the pain can he even write I don't know curly oh
no Oh god, what's happening on that ship?
Can we confront our mom?
Let's save and see.
Oh, it won't let me save yet.
Hold on.
Let me go into the meat plant.
We should save, though.
Save game.
I think we're okay to save over this one.
I haven't really done much, so...
Okay.
Yeah, we're going to go confront...
Let's see.
There's a cutscene for your mom entering the bedroom.
It's one of the best in the game.
I was trying to get her to...
Maybe I have to, like...
Okay, let's try.
We did just save, so let's do it.
Maybe if I keep examining the toys.
No.
Leave that there.
If any of it turns out missing.
Marv, what's going on in there?
Go.
No.
Okay.
Marv, what's going on in there?
I think it triggers during the night time.
Let me try three times, because, you know, like, that seems like a...
I mean, who knows what this game, honestly, but...
No, leave that there.
If any of it turns out missing.
Your dad, the origin story of the pain.
What's going on in there?
Go.
Okay, one last try.
One last time.
I want to hear it.
One more.
Oh.
Oops, I clicked exit!
Okay, I'm stupid.
Sorry, guys.
We'll try at night.
Mar.
What's going on in there?
Hello, dear.
How are you today?
By the way, I spoke with Mr. Johnson and he's living.
Oh my god.
If he finds out who, they'll be hectic.
They'll be hectic.
Congratulations, hero.
You found Karen after all.
Yeah, why?
I wonder why.
I warned you not to waste time looking for her.
Wait, we definitely skipped something on accident.
The blood drive is coming soon.
What does that have to do with anything?
If you haven't joined the lodge by then, you'll find out.
Still, I'm glad you found the poor baby.
Yeah, we sequence broke.
what happened to her what a silly little girl I can't well I did say but this is completely different than what I thought we were going to do are the ways of married couples why vtubers are so afraid to say if they're married wait do we need to protect Nimi no I think I think whoever Nimi is marrying is needs to be is the one that needs to be fear is wait is the one who is in trouble there we go I'll say I believe her shame on you imagine accusing your future father-in-law of a thing like that is that how a range rider would behave I don't think so why would she lie okay Wisenheimer even if he is a child molester a kidnapper and an attempted murder that's no reflection on what kind of father-in-law he'll be i just can't wait for the wedding can you oh bye don't forget to put the papers out for jimmy you know how he gets it's kind of it's so it's so creepy that she keeps bringing up jimmy he's gone mom he's gone jimmy james is gone i don't think i want to join this Yeah!
Seems bad, maybe.
Seems maybe not good.
I'm gonna save one more time.
Save.
Meat.
Meaty.
Meaty papers.
Buster just send the missile straight at us.
for real I don't think this ah sorry sorry I don't think this town needs to make it okay I brought my papers my meaty papers with permission so your father okayed the meat out how's he doing uh um uh that psychotic which has him slice to ribbons he's recovering nicely say it okay good good glad to hear it here's your meat son you run along now wait a new shipment of animals has come in and it's time to start cutting
oh chunk of meat animals he says he didn't even care he just was like okay whatever completely unfazed jimmy james will live on in our hearts.
Is Steve still a kidder?
Oh, yes, actually.
We did get the Steve as a kidder.
So now I'm guessing we have to go give this to Nightfall!
Oh, sorry, I just remembered the...
There we go.
Sorry, so sorry.
Wait, but...
Am I...
Um...
Save again.
It's
a good thing I saved.
Mom?
Why did she shoot me, Mom?
Oh my god.
Okay, I think maybe then...
Can I go to...
You want some meat?
Oh, I can't go in.
Okay.
Can I do it?
anything what's going on in there oh wait i can go inside even at night is it because i'm stealing
he loves oh he's a happy boy he's a happy boy operate the sheet ah he's just standing there geez what are you doing here Just standing here, waiting to be drawn.
You just hang out here.
All the time.
I'm not a person, Steve.
I'm an object.
You do well to remember that.
A person is his job.
Someday you'll understand that.
And if you don't, it won't matter because you'll be dead.
Oh, dead.
Have you gotten your lodge application in yet?
Yeah.
Uh, yes.
Good.
You may survive yet.
I guess you're here to steal the bolt.
How do you know that?
Are you gonna rat on me?
Not at all.
That's not my job.
My opinion on Zeus' mother has changed.
Since I am an object dart, and since art should be interpreted, I'll give you a clue as to where the bolt is located.
Darkness gives as darkness gets, but light invoked is light shed.
Uh, darkness...
What was it?
Darkness?
Still here, eh?
Where else would I go, Steve?
Yes.
Good.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
The mural?
Darkness.
What did he say?
Darkness something?
This game is very strange.
Yeah, it is.
Darkness...
This dude is a better method actor than Jared Leto.
Is that the Joker man?
Check the fireplace.
Something about light.
It's too high to reach.
Oh, do I use, like, the ladder?
All right.
You climb up and...
Receive a piece of cloth in the wall light.
Oh, I got it.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh, yeah.
There was just the Morbius and there was a Tron that just came out with him, too.
Crazy.
Okay.
All right, cool.
it having acquired the cloth you can make your way back to the house after an exhausting day
yeah we did day three
sensor oh because of his oh uh ah
wait i'm making it look more etsy than it really is
show me the burger of my future I made it look more sexy than it really was.
Oh, yeah, cheeseburger.
Be honest, I'm not judging or anything.
Were you so hairy as an 18-year-old?
Wargum.
So, yes, yes.
So it's not so bizarre, then.
Absolutely not.
Kind of, yeah.
He's just his...
I think it's really his outfit that makes him...
That ages him, too, you know?
Like, what 18-year-old is wearing this?
Um...
Since we...
Since we didn't talk to her yesterday, I missed crucial information.
Oh.
You know those firemen?
The funny ones with the color sense.
Looks like they misplaced a bolt of expensive...
fabric.
Of course, each one of them suspects the other.
Looks like a cat fight is brewing.
Well, not a cat fight.
The girls are fighting!
Bye.
Don't forget to put the papers out for Jimmy.
Jimmy's not coming back, mom.
Steve really dresses like my grandfather did.
I know!
It's truly the outfit.
Oh, I don't want to tell you.
This is the good part.
You're in trouble.
How's it feel?
be a jailbird.
How's it feel being a little punk, punk?
At least I'm not a jailbird.
You know what happens to jailbirds?
Just like turkeys and chickens, they wind up getting cooked.
There's like not a thought behind this, kids.
Fry.
Oh, it's too bad they don't give scalp badges for digging up buried kids.
I like to see what that badge would look like.
I went over to ask her what it was like being buried alive and all.
But she just stared at me and twitched and drew her.
Yes, I got my answer.
Huh.
What?
I can make that happen for you, Hank.
Good.
Finally.
You want to be buried alive?
I'm crazy now.
All right, let's see.
I feel like we can still save over the meaty papers.
I haven't really done that much.
okay um let's go give this to let's go get our new thingy um our new task i suppose exquisite cloth its loss should trigger quite a bit of dissension amongst our gallant fire fighters still that is not your concern your next assignment is to break to the dance or your establishment of Mr. Pastorelli and abscond with his prize that's mean!
He loves that thing though I kind of hate Hank I'm sure I'm not alone there.
Hank is terrible oh no but he's a barber he loves his barber pole thinking of opening a salon, Sarge lack of respect for authority
yes i approve stephen i hope you succeed in your task break into the shop steal the barber's bowl and bring it back
final task after this okay no i'm gonna feel so bad though okay um i'm glancing at the
uh okay i'm glancing at have to walk through.
We got that reward money and it's telling me to go here.
Hello.
Hello, Steve.
Hi.
Care to buy anything today?
Yes, please.
Just point to whatever you want.
I'm a little hard of hearing.
Okay.
Oh, oops.
Sorry.
Naughty fellas like Deputy Loomis aside, I think every man should cultivate an interest in girly magazines.
If it'll keep them out of the field of interior design, those fireman Betsy Betsy who's that no I'm Steve okay let's see um can I get a coffee no can I get some poison no right there's the tape black electrical tape you must pay how do I buy it though slightly used wrench you must pay mrs. Phelps before you get oh I think I have Whoops,
my bad.
I think I have to actually give her the money first.
I should cover it.
These 1950s prices are cheap.
Take what you need.
Oh, nice.
Okay, cool.
Pick it up.
That's mine.
Oh, no!
Not even coffee.
Alright, well, we got the tape and the wrench.
And, uh, we hobble to the, um, let's see, this is the barbershop, right?
Yeah.
Pastorelli.
That's right, everybody in here is so funny.
Hello.
Hello?
Oh, doesn't respond.
Not understanding English.
Oh, sorry.
Hello.
Uh, hello?
Oh, gosh, I don't know why my game is...
I keep clicking, but it's not happening.
The worst and the fire station full of sissies is a fire station full of pigs, sissies.
I like how this is like the drama of the town right now.
How the firefighters are angry at each other.
Boy, whoever said fight and fire with fire be happy and harvest because we got a fire station full of flamers.
Okay.
Bye.
Hello?
Nice to see you again, Steve.
Why is my...
Why is it not clicking?
What the heck?
Is it my mouse or is it the game?
I can't tell.
But when I click like that...
Okay, I'm just not going to talk to them.
What the heck?
Hmm...
Might be the game.
Um, when...
What else do I do?
Leave?
Uh...
What else do I do?
Oh.
Uh...
Wait, we could go see...
Ah!
Sorry.
How mad they are.
No, we cannot go see how mad they are.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Let's go see Stephanie.
Stephanie Hi My wife Steve It's so good to see you again I get so lonely in here Oh no I'm sorry Wanna hear what's happening out in the real world?
I'd rather forget about Harvest for a while So true Oh What's in here Huh?
What's happening?
Stephanie?
I feel so close to you, Steve.
Like we're the only two people in Harvest.
The only two real people.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah, I get it, I get it.
You've been shut up here too long.
No, no, I get it.
I need to feel something again.
This sense I have that I've known you.
It's my only link to my past.
Yeah.
It's different than memory.
Maybe we don't remember each other so much as we recall the feelings deep inside.
Strong feelings.
Maybe the body has its own memory.
Let's find out.
Oh, I want you to make love to me.
Say, say, say, say, say, say the sake.
I want you to.
Then take me now.
Yeah, I'll make it smaller for you guys.
Oh my god, she's...
Why?
She's having like a guard...
Guard her on.
What is that?
Ah!
Someone's watching!
Oh my god!
What is she doing?
What's going on?
Oh, we got kicked out.
Wait, why am I just standing there?
What just happened?
I don't think I needed the sensor, but...
I wasn't sure if they would show Nip.
Oh my...
Oh, quality time with...
A quality time with Stephanie.
Quality time with Snake.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh, I need to...
I need to leave.
Post-nut clarity hit him hard.
Okay, uh...
When does it become night time though?
Maybe I have to go to the lodge again to trigger it.
Exquisite car.
It's...
We did this though.
Freaky.
Eh?
Because I'm looking at the walkthrough.
And...
It's not telling me anything else, so I'm kind of confused.
It says to get the stuff at the general store and then go to the lodge, which I went to the lodge first, but whatever.
I guess...
And then it says it'll become night time.
Oh, when it's night.
So I guess let's go talk to people.
Anybody in here?
Hello?
Hello, Sheriff.
Dwayne Dwayne?
The way you keep pestering me, you'd think you were feeling guilty about something.
Are you?
What does that mean?
I got a report here that someone put a ding on Johnson's Tucker.
As honory as Johnson is about that old car, I suppose he had it coming.
I imagine it was just some kids pulling a prank.
Just a prank.
I know we're near solving the Tucker case.
And now I have to deal with a bunch of firemen throwing a hissy fit over some stolen cloth can you imagine what the heck is going on around here so true okay bye stop on by anytime steve i don't want to talk to this guy what's his name lumis i'm sorry i don't feel up right now with the talking that is okay thank goodness i don't want to talk to you either anytime kiddo bye
Let's go.
Edna's diner seems pretty safe.
Nice motorcycle.
Are you okay, Karen?
Bye-bye.
Okay.
I can't talk now.
The dishes are stacked up and back, and I better take advantage of the lull.
The lull.
I just heard that Mr. Johnson's Tucker was vandalized.
Everyone's talking about...
Oh, we should go talk to him.
Though I don't like to think ill of people and the misfortunes of others.
I'd like to think it's a comeuppance for all the times that nasty man has bothered me.
So true.
I feel terrible about what happened at the fire station.
Those firemen helped me decorate my diner.
Aww.
I can't believe one of them stole that cloth from the others.
It must have been someone else's in the fireplace.
Oh no, sorry, it wasn't in the fireplace.
It was in the light.
I'm so stupid.
Sorry.
It's because I examined the fireplace.
Oh my gosh, there's a scratch on it.
Sorry, my head is blocking it.
Look, there's a scratch on it.
Ugh, guys.
I think I'm stupid.
Um.
Stephanie hours.
Wait, no.
except for a huge gouge in the door oh my gosh oh wait I didn't mean to do that we did that though hello some rotten son bitch scratch my car oh he's crying my poor darling my sweet cheeks if I find out who did it I'll kill him just kill him dead I told that fool sheriff to beep off the patrols but what does he care of nobody cares about a limp dick fat boy well I'll make them care I'll make them care why couldn't they have scratched the hell out of that rickety fire truck instead of my tucker those firemen are carrying on like the world is ending just because someone stole some of their foo-foo claw someone ought to tell them that the world already ended i should know i feel like i feel like we're in purgatory good work rescuing karen of course you quit my play with This girl's life is more important than my sex life,
right?
Bye now.
The whiplash!
What is happening?
Charlie!
There were so many things happening at once!
what a guy truly it's not often that i get visitors i'm just oh okay bye all right we are testing everything what else um oh let's go talk to stephanie's dad maybe a i guess about karen oops i clicked the post office on accident i just am so
so funny gosh did you say hello to your father for me um I haven't wait I didn't save can I get out okay let's just say yes thank God for that at least I could use some good news right now I just got the word the order turned down my latest application oh looks like we'll be having the wedding at Moynihan's Oh,
the audio is a little...
Um...
I'm not quite sure what option to pick here.
When's the last time I say...
Oh, it was about Stephanie.
Okay.
Um...
Hmm.
I think we should...
Uh...
Hmm.
I think we should accuse him.
Yeah, I know what that...
crazy little bitch said, but it's not She's like seven!
I was at home that night.
Mrs. Pottsdam will vouch for me.
Isn't that right, Mrs. Pottsdam?
That's right, Mr. Pottsdam.
Hello, Steve.
Care to stay for some pot roast?
Forget the pot roast, mother.
Pot roast isn't for backstabbers.
For persecutors.
I won't share my meat with him.
My meat!
You always were a kid or minto.
Bye now.
Thank you for the same with that.
Why are you covering for him, Mrs. Pottsdam?
Wait, oh, there we go.
It's the truth.
That's why.
And I think you better be going, young man, before I call your mother and tell on you.
Oh.
Someone went and scraped up Johnson's car?
My meat!
he'd step in a bear trap and chew his own leg off rather than suffer he looks so much like jack black no he looks like rich from red letter media those silly willies down at the fire station are just incensed about losing some decorating stuff some people yeah yeah maybe they should be more concerned with fire and less with the flame okay bye i like how we're getting everybody's little commentary about the incidents but because I didn't talk to them about the what's it called talk to them about the scratch I'm talking to them all now at once so I'm getting everything all their opinions at once I fear how people will use that line in the future my meat he might want to be extra nice to mr.
Pottsdon today Steve he was turned down by the lodge again sorry I was yes we're having the wedding at mr.
Moynihan's after all he deserved it bye give my regards to your parents let's see okay yeah rip bozo say people I am okay hold on save game ask him about the people people hello people
If it isn't my favorite son-in-law, what brings you here again?
Peepo.
Peepole.
Beg pardon?
You've got a peephole in the upstairs bathroom.
It looks in on Stephanie's room.
Well, I'll be darned.
The second option!
Mrs. Potsdam's never been to Lebanon.
in her life someone's peeping in on Stephanie if it's not Mrs. Potsdam then who is it it's literally that vine no I'm American thanks for calling this to my attention Steve then you won't mind if I tell Stephanie about it now there's no need to scare Stephanie with this business I guess not so long as you patch that hole well I guess I could hang that picture somewhere else I thought you where it was.
Ooh!
Who else would it be?
Can I go tell her?
Oh, Stephanie, Stephanie!
Stephanie, Stephanie!
I'm glad to see you.
I feel so alone, cooped up in here.
My faux mother keeps me up on the latest gossip.
Oh.
Not like she really wants to talk to me.
More like she's feeding me in for me.
Right.
For instance, she told me that Mr. Johnson's Tucker was vandalized.
Yeah, I did that.
That's another weird thing.
Every car I've seen drive by is a Tucker.
There were only 31 produced.
What are the odds of that?
I've always wanted a Tucker.
Funny that Harvest would be full of them.
Any idea who scratched the car?
I did.
Me.
Why would you do something like that?
It's part of the lodge initiation.
I see look I don't know what's going on here, but getting into the lodge is the best way to find out By committing vandalism.
It was a prank.
Oh
It's a harmless enough prank.
It's just a prank.
It was a crime, Steve Don't be so melodramatic about it.
Uh-oh.
I've heard of worse fraternity initiations.
Sorry when you put it that way I guess I was overreacting you know the fireman someone stole some fabric from them and they're up in arms about it yeah it was me I took that another harmless prank and how many more harmless pranks will you be pulling however many it takes to get in Stephanie if I have to use them to escape than I will are you using them or are they using you it was just a bolt of cloth you've turned the firemen against each other they think one of their own stole it would you rather stay here I've heard that harvest is lovely in the fall when the leaves turn orange and gold and the annual blood drive paints the town red all right all right you have a point is it true you found Karen yeah Yeah,
just in time, too.
He'd molested her and buried her alive.
He couldn't bring himself to kill her outright, so he just decided to stick her in the ground and let fate take its course.
Who would do that to a helpless child?
She says it was Mr. Potsdam, and I believe her.
Oh, Christ.
And all this time, I've been under the same roof with that thing watching me.
Take it easy, okay?
Take it easy.
At least he'll be coming to take him away, won't they?
Oh, so if I tell you peephole, peephole.
Stephanie, I think you should know there's a peephole hidden behind the picture in the bathroom.
You mean a peephole?
How does she not?
But shouldn't she see the hole in the wall?
So that's the scraping I hear every night.
The picture sliding along the wall.
Oh my god.
What?
Disgusting.
I've got to get out of here, Steve.
I thought of that fat slob watching me.
I confronted Potsdam about it.
He tried to play dumb, but I got him to say he'd fix it.
Thank you, Steve.
I don't know what I'd do without you.
Oh my gosh, we did good.
We did good!
Yes, let's go.
Come back and visit me soon.
Okay?
Bye, Stephanie.
I hope we can woo-hoo again later.
Nice!
We did good.
Woo-hoo!
Okay, cool.
Is it night time yet?
Guys, how do I make a night?
Um...
Let's go talk to people at the post office.
Maybe talk to the general.
Hello, Postmaster Boyle.
Sorry, son.
No time to talk.
Neither rain nor sleep nor snow nor hair.
hell shall keep the mail from its appointed rounds.
Woo-hoo.
Next time you post, don't forget the zip code.
Don't forget the zip code.
Zip code map with harvest dead center.
Can I leave?
How do I get out of here?
Get me out of here.
There we go.
Do I have two screwdrivers?
I have a wrench.
I'm taping.
I have one screwdriver.
Do I need two?
A screwdriver at the...
Diner.
Okay.
Maybe?
One more.
Okay, I didn't know that.
Oops.
Ah, yeah, but...
Okay.
At the diner.
There's one in here?
Where would it be?
It's hard to find.
Is that it?
No.
Middle left.
Examine the drawer.
Oh, sorry.
I accidentally clicked too fast.
Oh my gosh.
How are you supposed to see that?
This town is a bit screwy.
I'll take that.
How are you supposed to see that?
Holy moly.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, well, thank you so much.
Ah, here we go!
The way everyone says Steve feels like they're on family view.
Yay!
Oh my gosh, you saved me!
Thank you, thank you!
Gosh, how are you supposed to do that?
Alright, to the...
But we got to talk to a lot of people, so that's always kind of fun.
the barbershop is closed
I have a closet key broom closet key use it with my axe
um yeah we're breaking in but how so I think I need to use the electrical tape on something because I Oh, oh, what?
Well, I was going to say just because I bought it.
But okay.
The wrench?
Ow!
Weeks of fun, more like years.
Okay, we've made it.
The sheep.
Except for the occasional hairball cough, it's hard to tell if the sheep is alive or not.
Wait, but the barber pole...
What is this picture?
Picture of young Mr. Pastorelli.
Spaghetti in his mouth and all.
I want spaghetti.
Sounds good.
Fancy barber pole secured to the wall.
Oh.
The screws.
We'll use it.
Oh.
Oh, that's why.
Because it said it was a...
This is the straight slot screwdriver.
And this is a Phillips...
Oh.
Ah!
Did I get arrested?
Oopsie.
Wait, why?
This is your second arrest.
Ah!
You just remember, one more strike, and you're out.
Oopsie.
Oh.
Wait, I'm actually in the...
Iron stains streak the inside of the jail sink.
Deputy Loomis' favorite hot spot.
Ew!
The next inmate will get to use this rickety cot as a bed.
Tint cup looks like a prop.
right out of an Alcatraz movie.
The toilet's connecting copper pipe is loose.
Oh, can I take it?
Oh, okay.
Thanks.
Wait, now you can't use the toilet, though.
The jail gate is locked.
Free pipe?
Well, that didn't work.
Ah!
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Jailbreak?
Dismantled sink?
I'll take that.
Okay.
Well, that didn't work.
Damn it.
What?
Oh, I could just leave.
Oh, no, I can't.
I think I should reload anyway.
Honestly.
What did I do wrong?
Oh, dang.
We have to go back to the diner.
Oh, I think I'm gonna sneeze.
Ah.
Eh.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Sorry.
I'm fine.
I took some...
What's it called earlier?
Some...
medicine.
Because my nose was... Ugh.
Ugh.
Made my head all cloggy.
I don't know why I can't sneeze on stream, you guys.
Once I start talking about a sneeze, I can't sneeze.
I just can't do it.
I don't know why.
Okay.
Alright, let's try again.
I don't know why stealing the barber pole set off the alarm, but not um...
But not breaking the door down, sure, whatever.
What else can we use to bust down the door?
Pitchfork.
Oh my gosh, it worked!
The phantom sneeze.
Jim Bob, who was the high school star pitcher 20 years ago, hangs his aging letter jacket here.
When he comes here for a trim.
Oh, operate the light switch.
Wait, why?
Oh, it turned it off.
Okay.
Maybe that will do it.
Yeah.
Okay.
We made it.
Having acquired your barber pole, you make your way to the house.
Okay, cool.
Now my nose is all runny.
I-I-I did the, what's it called, the nose spray.
Because I wanted my nose to not be running.
Ah!
What do you people want from me?
Cheeseburger.
Oh my god, his eyes are popping out!
I saved you.
No woohoo tonight.
We got the woohoo though earlier.
It's crazy.
Press Ctrl F4 and click the left mouse button.
Oh.
Oh, I did it.
Disc 2!
Woohoo!
Disc 2- Disc swap!
Let's go.
All right, let's save though.
Save.
Control.
F4.
And left click.
Okay.
This is a hefty game, huh?
Ma'am!
Good morning, mother!
Hello, dear.
How are you today?
Did you hear what happened at the bar?
barber shop?
Someone broke into Pastorelli's salon and took his antique barber's pole.
The next morning, Pastorelli touched some live wires that the thief left lying around and was electrocuted.
Well, that darn foreigner got what he deserved if you ask me.
What?
Come into a nice little town like harvest and stealing business.
There's no other barber's here!
If a bowl of scissors were good enough for your father, I don't see why decent working folk need a fancy wap styling their hair.
That's how it goes.
First you get a sissy then bang you're a communist isn't it exciting steve five days and 1200 cookies later the bake sale is already here where does the time fly where does the time fly one thousand two hundred cookies how many are you taking to the sale but how many oh the rest is tail but the effort wasn't wasted it's for a good cause what is happening oh um wouldn't miss it that's nice dear be open to new experiences.
Thanks for protecting our innocence.
Of course.
Wait, good cause.
Yeah, I got you with the sensors.
Having a fake sale to pay for burying out-of-towners?
Goshahoodies, what should we do?
Leave them in the streets?
Of course we should bury them.
But why do so many out-of-towners drop dead in harvest?
Yeah.
I have wondered about that, and I think it has something to do with the air.
But there's nothing wrong with the air.
It's perfectly clean.
That's what I mean.
Big city folk, they get so used to smog that clean air is a shock to their systems.
Gets them every time.
Okay, bye, mom.
Don't forget to put the papers out for Jimmy.
No, no, Jimmy James, please.
It's true.
It's really shocking their system.
Oh my goodness gracious.
I don't want to talk to Hank.
I don't like him.
She won't let me forget Jimmy.
They were like, you killed him.
This is my purgatory.
This is so...
Oh my gosh.
Okay, we gotta go to the lodge.
And give them the pole.
I hope nobody looks in my pockets.
And here it is.
The object dog.
Imported by shinglass.
And Italian dreams.
Italian dreams.
Oh, mama bea.
Oh my gosh.
that pastorelli was electrocuted because you left live wires wait he's alive though right but it's those with affectations of worldliness say say love you wait is he alive did i kill him
pastorelli took a big spill a permanent
he's dead
voodoo yes a barber cut down in his prime Of course.
You only wanted the pole.
But that hardly matters now.
Your final assignment is to set Avaya in D-N-A's diner and let the French fry where they may.
What does that mean?
Wait, is this still a prank?
Guys, this is it.
That's the gateway prank.
The gateway prank is...
somebody's car and then then before you know it you're accidentally electrocuting people and then you're setting fires i is is is edna french yes i suggest you succeed beyond that you must find your own answers members of the order must be resourceful and cunning it's like how you Jimmy James.
This whole town is a prank.
Tonight, the bake sale commences.
Soon, the annual harvest blood dry...
We graduate from pranks to a little bit of trolling.
When sacrifice will be the order of the day, your time in harvest grows short.
Does everyone just die during the blood dry?
What is happening?
look like a cross between edward norton and voice critical i don't who uh i don't know edward norton tonight to the bake sale commences okay um i is at the school uh
what's going on at the diner anyway
karen is still traumatized bye bye oh god she can't see anything else i can't talk now okay i've whipped up a huge batch of brownies for the pta bake sale tonight i just wish i could do more to help out those poor bombs um how will the what time is the bake sale i think it starts at six and runs until 10 o'clock dang that's late i hope to see you there say it's my birthday was electrocuted he's dead it looks like some thief wanted his barber's pole but didn't think of the consequences maybe it's what the guy had to do sorry Maybe whoever was really needed that barber's pole bad.
That's no excuse for hurting someone else.
Even if Pastorelli were alive now, his heart would be broken.
And what's a little profit compared to that?
Whoopsie!
My bad.
This is my birthday!
It's Avina!
Happy birthday!
Does Amir, does he sound like Urukai General from Return of the King?
Yeah.
exit sign.
But I have to do the exit other exit sign.
Um, okay.
Well, 6 to 10.
We haven't gone here in a bit.
The guy in the top hat.
Yeah, she keeps expressing morals.
Why am I...
I've been only talking to the people that are like...
Oh gosh, the sounds.
I've been only talking to the people or rather pulling pranks on the people that are...
Are, like, decent.
A young man lies motionless in the casket.
Red stains are visible on his shirts and boots.
Wait, what?
Who are you?
I thought it was gonna be Mr. Pastorelli.
Why are we...
Why are we stripping him?
Oh my god.
My Yeti hand.
Oh, sorry.
I did the same thing.
My bad.
Yeah, why is our first instinct to do that?
Tommy!
Did we take a picture of it?
Oh, you take a photo of the body.
Okay.
I don't think that's the pastor, right?
That's what I thought.
Or not the...
Uh, uh, the...
Not the pastor.
Sorry, I read your comment.
That pastor, Mr. Relly.
No, I think the barber.
What was his name?
Pastor Relly.
Um, okay, I'm gonna look at the cut.
Uh, the...
The guide.
Walk through.
Um...
Okay.
Use your camera, take a photo, bring it to Mr. Moynihan.
That's, uh, this guy, isn't it?
Mr. Moynihan?
Um...
Is that this guy?
And the pastor, Barbarelli.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
We haven't talked to him at all in a bit, so let's talk to him.
Young man, we really have nothing to say to each other.
I have the feeling your image shall soon adorn my slab.
And I'd rather not know the face of the meat I'm slicing.
Why do you think that?
It seems that like some elephant's graveyard, people of low station come to harvest and die.
drop dead, penniless, and they all need burials.
Why are they dying?
Like that corpse in the chapel.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All dressed up and nowhere to go.
No mourners.
Now point that I still must provide them with prompt burials by town charter.
He didn't just drop dead, he has those weird scars on them.
God knows by putting these people up at the Wayward Hotel, I do more than my fair share.
So why must I pay for the coffins and burial materials as well?
My losses to the dead are hopefully the bake sale will offset some of them I do hope you'll attend the bake sale and spend heavily oh it's for the needy you know sure and all they have to do to benefit is die a ditch makes a poor resting place you'll need to learn brownies maybe if you ever want to leave harvest you make it sound like I have a choice a choice that is rapidly vanishing yeah join the lodge Steven while you happened at the blood drive the corpse the corpse reclining in the chapel right now is a prime example of the difficulties I face for unfathomable reasons this bum decided to wander into harvest and summarily drop dead just like that indeed he died of purely natural causes of that I have no doubt but why come to harvest to die yeah you say this happens often isn't that a they're like a drawn to a flame.
I've often puzzled over the situation myself, though I can assure you, young man, that nothing untoward is happening in Harvest.
Sure.
On the contrary, it's an indication of our compassion that I put up hobos in the wayward hotel, and the order of the Harvest Moon mandates their prompt burial, even when they are without family or means, and when it entails losses on my part.
I think the lodge is trying to see if I'm a psychopath.
And we'll kill people coming into the town.
Okay, so we have to give him...
I'd say it's been a pleasure.
I'd have to give him the photo.
But I find the company of the living so wearisome.
Am I going to eat somebody?
Oh, wait.
I want to see it.
Little Tommy.
That...
Oh.
Take this.
My checky.
Ah, you've taken it.
taken up photography I see now why on earth would you choose such a grotesque subject that John Doe you got boxed up in the chapel he didn't just drop dead yeah someone helped him take the plunge yeah you may be right I'm a mortician not a medical examiner you don't have to be to know that being ripped to shreds can be detrimental to your I think ripped to shreds is a little dramatic to be looking into young man is that a threat to Yeah,
is that a threat?
Or I just want to find out who I am and how to get out of here.
Oh, actually, I don't know which one.
Two shreds you set.
Why are you guys all quoting that?
Minimum, minimum, minimum.
Get the tiger minds down.
Let me all just let him go.
My mom said to pick the very best one and you are it.
Okay, one.
That's what we all want.
It's about trying to get out.
What game are you people playing?
A game we win or lose together.
Look, are you going to tell me what I want to know?
Or do I go to the sheriff with these pictures?
That would be a grave mistake, I assure you.
I've told you all I can.
My losses have been substantial.
The sounds are so...
The only thing I can give you in exchange for the photographs...
Is my tube of astro glue.
Let me take it.
That's all you'll get from me.
Oh.
Uh.
Okay.
We get some glue.
A wise decision.
When a wasp's nest is stirred up, it is seldom the wasps who grieve later.
Can we take it to the wasps?
Is that a hint?
Okay, we got some glue.
Oh!
It's already not.
Oh my gosh, we're going to the big sale!
Okay, we're not using...
That was so fast.
Okay.
Yeah, now we have a little...
He gave us a snack.
All right, let's go to the...
It's at the school, right?
I'm gonna save real quick.
A little snack for the...
road.
Bye.
I can't follow.
Thank you so much for the time.
Thank you.
Uh, examine.
It looks like the bake sale will be held here.
Where?
In, in, in here.
Oh.
In here.
Okay.
Oh.
Gymnasium rules.
1.
No blood on the floor.
2.
Do unto others as they would do unto your mother.
3.
No laughing.
4.
No sports allowed.
Minto with a little snack for the road.
You can't eat me.
Buy some cookies?
It's for a good cause.
Mmm.
You all look alike.
Mercy.
What a terrible thing to say.
Isn't it late?
Yes, terrible.
What a good boy you are.
Have a cookie.
Thank you.
To hell with your cookies.
Why, I never.
Isn't that right, ladies?
Yes, never.
Oh no, it's, they're weird, they're weird.
Uh, can I go anywhere?
Wait, I saw exit here.
Ladies, someone has just burned down the TV station.
It wasn't me.
On the night of our bake sale?
All colors.
Thank you so much for the 10 gifts.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
On the night of our bake sale?
Um, let's go to the TV station, I guess.
Wait, who's that?
Oh my god, it's on fire!
The TV station is closed.
No, kidding.
Oh, it was the postman!
Um, well, if I go to the diner...
Diner's locked up.
Hold on, I'm looking at the guide.
Go to the...
Oh, break in the same way you broke into the barbershop.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh.
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to save real quick.
Now I'm going to save a little snack on the road.
There we go.
And then we'll use the axe this time.
Yeah.
Nice pink car.
Hey!
Um...
Oh, what is this?
Examine the cake cover.
A cake?
Oh, pick it up.
What's there?
Examine the grease fryer.
Grease fryer's off.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Um.
Wait, there's a smoke alarm.
Maybe.
We use this to cover it up.
Damn it.
Okay, no.
Fry's in the bag, me and Toe.
With the tape, maybe?
Damn it.
No?
The glue?
You apply the glue to the rim of the cake cover.
Oh, my gosh, I'm a genius.
We covered it.
Okay.
have matches yes yeah did you just say yeah oh my god I'm sorry Edna with Edna's diner ablaze your task is complete you carefully make your way home to avoid any possible witnesses
Oops.
I'm sorry, Edna.
How will these people...
Oh, they'll all be forced to eat only the meat.
Because the diner is closed.
Oh, uh, ah!
Ah!
I'm about to take my praxis exam for my teacher licensure.
Can I get a mid-spentum?
Good luck, charm.
Wait, hold on.
Watch this...
Watch this dream sequence.
And imagine the cheeseburger.
Good luck, Evan!
You got this!
You got this.
Good luck!
Wee!
Oh my gosh.
It's already, what, day seven?
Because we...
Lost a day.
was that our last task i think
so two buildings burned down last night
there's a scene next time you enter the diner you may want to give a warning for it can be upsetting oh okay i don't know what kind of warning to give but i will hello dear how are you today the nerve of some people burning down the tv station to detract from our Oh yeah,
wait, Hank can't be watching TV now.
Just to annoy the Harvest PTA.
Coincidence?
I don't think so.
Just six months ago, the newspaper building went up in smoke.
Obviously, there's a firebug on the loose.
A firebug.
She's obsessed with communists.
What's communism got to do with anything?
Just ask Colonel Monroe at the missile base.
He'll tell you.
Okay.
Now that the big sale's over, I just don't know how I'll fill my time.
Oh, I feel so...
useless my goodness what's wrong with her oh
it's not as bad as it looks you just pop them back in see
as good as new that tarantula she ate must have had wasp eggs in it don't you think we should get her to a doctor what for she's got her mother how silly i was feeling useless just because there are no more cookies to bake i can still rear my brood what does that mean this is a sign steve i have a purpose again glad to see you're feeling better mind that fire still burns my britches first the newspaper building then dna's diner then whar i sense a pattern and any pattern i can't make a dress out of is no darn good i suppose you heard about dna dine are burning down sheriff dwayne thinks it was a grease fire we took a black eye on the bake sale but i'm sure the harvest pta annual blood drive will be more successful overall we made about 200 dollars hardly enough to bury a dead horse and definitely not enough to cover the annual blood drive um i
think the babies i can't get over like how the edits look like they're done in ms paint and like and like just kind of like edited on but they look so poorly done so
oh the annual blood drive annual blood drive huh if you knew how much blood we get you'd be more impressed donations are mandatory steve if you're still here come sunday you'll be expected to give until it hurts i suppose until it hurts even hank have to donate of course lodge members are exempt remember that hey either way no one's sticking me with the needle we don't use needles oh hang hang that kid over by the television your little brother is homesick from school today and i won't have you scare him with this amnesia poop is he really sick yeah he's been sick for days he's watching wouldn't you say he's sick i'd make cookies for the harvest ppa charity bake sale it's on friday you know oh i hope you're still wait okay this is this is old dialogue okay hold on sorry all right we'll just leave it's fine don't oh okay jimmy james sorry yeah she's gone in a loop what are you watching hank what is it now hank what why are you sitting in front of that blank tv someone burnt down the tv
channel there's nothing wrong honestly Hank you're acting like an alcoholic I told you all that TV would hurt you watching TV don't hurt me mom but not watching TV hurts bad oh my god if I find out who burnt down the TV station I'll make him wish he was one of those damn Indians good finally Hank needs help actually everybody in this town needs i think we should just just just burn it all down hey hello thank you so much for the vibe good to thank you tell him it was the postman i'm not gonna rat i'm no snitch okay wow that was a lot let's uh
the baby is sick Hank is me when there's no Minto stream.
There's...
The stream doesn't hurt me.
It's when there's no stream that it hurts me.
Oh boy, golly.
Oh, sorry.
The game is getting crazy.
I mean, it was already crazy.
Let's go see what's going on at the TV station first.
Hello, range rider Say can you spare a dime for a buckaroo who's down on his luck?
Wait, it the game is it wait the game it Wait, it Wait, I'm clicking but nothing's happening.
Say oh, oh my god Who's down on his luck the whole shebang just went up in flames and I'm looking to mosey on to greener pastures Oh my god!
Freddy Krueger!
Was he inside?
Oh my god!
Say, he's a buckaroo.
He's just a buckaroo down on his luck!
oh wait we can go in it's kind of crazy oh my god wait what's this
I've tried so hard to find an excuse to keep on fighting but Karen and I can't go out alone oh oh oh oh YouTube don't look YouTube don't look who's always a struggle to keep it running in such a small town and now we've lost it I know that I can't afford to support this now there's only one way out YouTube especially hates scenes like this understand the depth of despair that would enable a mother to put a rope around her baby's neck and push her into the air and jump after her I wonder if I'll hear her next it was just a prank if she kicks around and a long time he strangles how scary but i won't cut her down i've got to be strong in minecraft yeah everything in minecraft everything in minecraft but i hope she doesn't care god help us and forgive us pedna fitzpatrick oh okay okay i thought we were gonna see oh oh oh okay oh it's it's oh Oh,
bug out.
She's hiding in.
Oh, oh, bug God.
And she's eating.
They're right in front of you.
In front of my salad.
Well, um...
Oh, golly.
Oh, okay, let's just save so we don't have to watch that again.
We'll save over this one.
Yeah, the baby.
The baby is sick.
What happened?
Um, uh, we won't be seeing Edna or Karen anymore.
They went upstate.
They moved out of harvest.
Thank goodness, right?
Yeah, a sewer slide.
Okay.
Um, all right, I'm going to look at the guide to see what we do here.
Okay, visit Stephanie.
We'll get over it by visiting our girlfriend.
It's all good.
I guess we do have to go...
Wait, let's all...
Wait, let's go to the lodge first.
let's go to the lodge first since i want to know what they say dna's diner is no more as is edna herself she hung herself i don't think you should tell her about this one i don't think so chief i think we should lie to her for this one to her beloved establishment a true entrepreneur and a credit to her nation the captain went down with her ship No idea!
Come now.
I really did.
Anyone who spoke with her for five minutes would have known what a tragedy the destruction of her diner would be.
We could put the bake sale towards her.
You sought to torture diner and torched it is.
You have proven yourself a worthy candidate for initiation.
What if Mr. Potsdam burying Karen was one of his initiators?
And because he got caught, that's why they rejected him.
Look, look, welcome to Mambushabdaku!
I thought this was the initiation.
Yeah.
This was only a trial to determine your worthiness for testing.
Your initiation into the mysteries of the harvest will soon begin.
In the meantime, be patient.
Mm-hmm.
Protocols must be observed.
...before initiation may commence.
How I recognize this sign.
Yeah.
You will know.
When you receive the invitation, bring it here.
And your initiation shall begin.
You're invited to the initiation.
Okay.
I'll wait for my...
I'll wait for...
I'll wait for my little card in the mail.
Alright, now let's go see Stephanie.
I
don't know.
My...
Oh.
Me-meet-meet-me-boy.
Oh, he's gone.
Almost made of leather.
polyester is he upstairs oh hello mr.
Potsdam guess I can forget about the meat huh what do you mean yeah what do you mean your dad must have pulled some strings be sure and check Stephanie's pillow you lucky bum what the hell are you talking about what does that mean yeah you'll see once the sheriff gets here Stephanie Stephanie what things will never be the same now Wait,
what?
Guess I'll be watching TV nights.
Okay, you can come in now, son.
What happened?
Stephanie dead?
Oh my god.
Is that what I think it is?
She's been reduced.
Yes, it's a spinal cord.
Is it...
Stephanie?
I can see a resemblance, but I can't be sure.
More pie, Sheriff.
Pie.
Skeletons knife!
Don't you realize what's happened?
Oh, indeed I do.
I can just hear the tongues wagging at the PTA.
Was it?
What?
Suicide.
Wait.
I've never heard of anyone pulling their own spinal cord out before.
Off the record, I'd have to say, nope.
No, all in all, I'd say this was death by natural causes.
natural causes natural causes you can't live without a spinal cord son nothing unnatural about that think i will have some more power no at least we got to woohoo with her i can't believe this this is horrible believe me you get to the point to where this is Routine.
Routine!
There's like 50 people in this town!
Now the only clue we got is that card on our pillow.
Take a look at it.
This is practically a confession.
Confession to what, son?
Murder.
Isn't that what you're here to investigate?
We got our invitation.
Son, you don't investigate natural deaths.
No point.
Then I'll get to the bottom of this myself.
I know.
I'm sure you will.
Yummy.
More pie, Sheriff.
What?
She's giving it to me.
Don't mind if I do.
What did the actors think?
I truly have to know.
What did they think when they were filming this?
Oh my.
Steve is in Super Smash.
Oh my god, I can't believe Jesus is just a skeleton.
Oh my god!
Oh, I guess I see why the guide told me to go talk to Stephanie before talking to the lodge.
Because we would have been able to talk to her.
But it's fine.
Oh, I see now.
I thought I almost had a bad ending for it.
second or something.
Why is it working?
I don't know.
She's just a skull and a little spine.
Oh my god.
Just got back.
How's Stephanie?
She's she's skinny.
Examine the skull and the spine.
I'm clicking.
Oh, Oh, a lodge invitation.
Let's take that.
Yoink.
Can I take her too?
A skull and a spinal cord.
I died.
Steve's model took being a kid or two seriously.
What do you mean?
The actors were thinking, God, I hope this check clears.
Seriously.
I am always thinking about the death by natural causes line.
Oh, it's gotta be death by natural causes.
Hello, Steve.
Have some pie?
Um, another skeleton in the family closet, eh?
No, Steve.
We're going to put her in the crypt.
Oh!
Keeping bodies in the house is just not sanitary.
Must have been a moth, ma'am, because now she's now boneless.
No!
driven to take their own spine it couldn't be i can't believe what was that with a line from that neil brain movie i can't believe you killed yourself i cannot believe you killed yourself why wait
you guys know that video of like the person that's like singing those they're like singing a song They're like, you suicidal?
Suicidal?
Why?
Oh, suicidal?
Suicidal?
Pfft, pfft, pfft, pfft.
That's what the mom was about to say.
I don't suppose it'd hurt for you to take the card.
Seeing as it was addressed to you.
Yeah, I took it.
I'm sorry I had to read it in the first place.
But that's my job.
I wonder if there's more pie.
Why?
The pie must be really good.
What kind of pie is it, I wonder?
It's probably a meat pie.
Oh.
You okay?
What do you want?
You know, with a slaughterhouse full of meat in town, what kind of nutcase would steal a barber's?
He's talking about the barber.
Your daughter is dead!
Pastorelli won't need it where he is.
Sweetie Todd.
Harvest will never be the same without DNA's diner.
Or without DNA.
for that matter it's kind of messed up they just call it dna diner it's not his it's not his name um
okay well uh let's go to the lodge i can't i guess we're calling off the wedding no like you know what we saw what happens with married people so maybe it's for the best
You received the invitation, but you have not brought it.
Right, where?
Oh.
What?
I don't understand.
The invitation was not the card.
Ah.
A spinal cord.
It must be presented to me.
Air, I allow you to enter.
Uh...
What have you done with Stephanie?
Stephanie?
They'll be, they'll get mad at me though.
You expect me to steal the remains and bring them here?
I expect nothing.
What must unfold will...
Okay.
You were provided an invitation.
The skull and the spinal cord.
Okay, okay.
I don't think this is the morgue guy unless he's putting on a crazy voice.
How would we not recognize him?
Go back.
Unless she's at the cemetery already.
Excuse me, everybody.
Oh, no, she's gone!
Oh.
Stephanie, she had nice taste.
Stephanie, my Stephanie.
That's all I have to say about hers.
She had nice taste.
Okay.
Yeah, and the crypt maybe or at the morgue we'll check both are you okay hello steve have some pie you don't happen to have stephanie's spine lying around do you no steve i'm so sorry you just missed it oh we just had her bones interred in the family vault in the cemetery oh dang okay stop by there if you want to pay your last respects but you can't get inside it's sealed when will it be back oh um i can i can Alright,
I'll figure that out.
I think we're just gonna embrace being a full-blown, uh, like, insane guy.
We're just gonna, you know...
Stephanie, my Stephanie, I'm coming for you.
That's a spirit!
The marble doors have been sealed shut.
Can I climb the tree?
The leaning sycamore is dead rotten and unstable for climbing or stringing nooses!
That's not what I was thinking.
Oh no.
Um, oh.
Can I climb with this?
Oh, here's the ladder!
Okay.
There's a skylight.
A dim light shines through the glass skylight.
I'm breaking it.
Okay.
Ah!
Oh my god!
Uh, uh, uh, oh, I don't think my pistol has, uh, oh my god, what the hell was that?
What
was that?
Wait, where's her operate the ladder back up?
That was the biggest rat I've ever seen!
Stephanie.
A skull and spinal cord.
Yoink.
Okay.
Let's uh...
Let's head back.
Yeah, we just put that in our pocket.
Easy storage.
The way he walks with the axe.
What's our health level?
I have no idea.
Oh, maybe this is our health?
At the bottom?
Not quite sure.
How did I have it?
You know, let the initiation commence as your mystagogue mystagogue requested and required that i turn over this sacred dagger sacred dagger oh my health is steve's photo okay okay whoa what is this
you must now enter the lodge we're going into the lodge the shits find it a hostile place oh it's hostile are you supposed to help me or get me kill it's an h on the path of initiation to a very special very exclusive brotherhood I am merely the administrator of a test whether you view me as an enemy or a friend depends on how well you're prepared to pass all right this thing you haven't said what it is it is a special show weapon using it will be part of the initiation yeah how do you use it um no fine i'll use it if i have to you always have a choice initiate which choices you make okay are we oh whoa mucho texto is relevant to the great question which you cannot help but answer at issue is whether in answering the question you will find the answers you seek you will encounter those intent on preventing or prompting your answer depending on how you're kidding huh while the assumption is you want to live Dying is easy and requires its own answer.
Just tell me, is Stephanie dead or being held within?
The membership director on the second level keeps track of such things.
Oh great, then you are against me.
I am the sergeant at arms.
I am here to ensure that the protocols are absurd.
Right.
Deviation from a protocol shall result in punishment.
Remember what I have told you.
So we use the...
Now let the initiation begin.
Woohoo!
Oh my gosh, it's open!
Another disk?
Control F.
Control...
Wait, control...
F4.
Left click.
There's another disk?
Oh.
Valet.
Examine the bust.
Okay, hold on.
Before we do that, we're gonna save.
We blasted through Disc 2.
I know.
Okay, um, is there more saves?
No.
So we're gonna have to start rewriting over things.
I am...
I... I'm gonna lose all my memories.
Sad.
Save often.
Okay.
Um, uh, lodge, lodging it up, baby, one.
Part one.
Goodbye, Steve.
Okay.
Oh, you're here.
Oh, my God!
You'll find them through that door.
Excuse me?
You are the exterminator.
Are you not?
No.
In that case, I'm afraid you'll have a hard time of it, sir.
Recently, the lodge has become infested by pests.
They need exterminating, or to be blunt, sir, they need killing.
Okay.
And plenty of...
Oh, okay.
I didn't click anything.
Okay.
Um...
Oh, what's the quickest way to the second level?
Yeah.
The second floor, sir?
The entrance is hidden.
Oh.
But a little reflection should reveal the answer.
Okay.
To find the key to the second floor, reach deep within yourself.
I wish you good luck, sir.
I only hope you can stomach what's ahead.
Yeah, mirror probably.
All right, so let's equip our...
Oh!
We lost everything!
I changed the music.
This bust of Beethoven glares down at you in silent rebuke.
Thomas Jefferson, Benjamin Franklin, George Washington, Barbara Bush.
One of these things is not like the other.
Actually, maybe two of them.
Sure.
Okay, wait, where do I go?
Go?
Where do I go?
Oh!
Okay, we're prepared now.
Blueish veins line the mucus slick walls.
Ooh!
Let's examine the floor.
The surface underfoot is oddly spongy and fluid oozes up around your shoes where you step.
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm just gonna save so that we can...
Okay, lodging it up, baby, let's go!
If we get attacked...
Oh!
It looks like a butthole.
Exit, uh...
I can exit this way.
Exit this way?
Ah!
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
Shell lodged deep in the porous wall.
It looks like a cocoon of some sort.
Oh yeah, easy, easy.
these examine
the mushroom a tomb tomb scent mushroom soaking in the puddle of bot what does that mean there's so many places to go wait okay let's go back the other way okay so they don't respawn that's kind of nice this way let's try this way
Okay, how's my health?
We're fine.
A polyp grows stealthily.
A tumorous growth erupting from the fleshy prison.
Where?
What is happening now?
Why is...
Um...
Two fleshy.
Four out of ten.
Alright, let's keep going.
We're doing a whole colonoscopy.
What?
This place is huge!
Okay, hold on.
I'm looking at the guide real quick.
Kill all enemies with their harvester blade.
Walk into the room with the eyeballs in it.
Okay, where do I find such a place?
Am I going?
I can't tell if I'm looping or not, you know?
I can't.
It looks like I'm looping, I think.
Yeah, we're definitely looping.
Okay, so we gotta go through the hole.
In here.
Oh!
Oh, what is this?
Okay, okay, nice.
Okay.
Examine the big eye.
It's a big blue eye looking like it.
right at you.
And you thought the walls had ears.
Funny.
He's got jokes.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh!
Oh.
Upon leaving the strange rooms behind, you notice a burning feeling in your skin.
You also notice a gooey film of slime covers your clothes.
Are we okay?
We're fine.
Okay.
um wait okay it could be that you have acid on your clothes if that's the case you need to clean it off really quicker you'll die okay i'm reading the guide first enter the door in the middle how do i how do i clean it
now your hp drains throughout the run what oh my god okay um enter the door in the middle.
Okay, I'm just gonna follow the guide for this part, then.
Holy cow, did I
get bit?
Uh-oh.
Wait, we're not so cheery anymore, guys.
Ah!
Kill the monster.
Go to the... Go right into a bar.
Okay.
Um, this way?
Wait.
I want to examine a little.
They must have disagreed with something that ate him.
Wait.
What?
I'm in a bar.
A bar stocked with only domestic beers.
It's a player piano with the inscription Chicago on it.
Okay, we're not looking so...
We're not looking so hot.
I don't want to die.
We're suddenly Red Dead Redemption.
Do I go in here?
Um.
What the hell is that?
Oh.
Feed me, Seymour.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
We gotta go back.
We gotta do the shells here.
Examine the beer.
Have a drink.
Oh.
Don't mind if I do.
You take the beer and drink it.
The strong beer.
The room spins and your vision blurs momentarily.
Oh!
Ah!
Um...
We get to unlock something.
We got a small key.
Okay.
What?
What is going on?
A bar key.
Alright.
Is there a... something back here?
Maybe not.
Steevel.
This is where we came from.
Wait.
Examine the mirror.
This dust covering mirror reflects a darker image of yourself.
That's what we just killed!
Ah!
No, no!
How did we get a black eye from the acid?
Wait, hold on.
The cash register in the back, did I miss it?
I don't want to save just yet because we wait I didn't see a cash register did you guys oh I don't see a cash register oh here here take
the money to $100 bills don't mind if I do five dollars don't mind if I do okay so now we got to go get cleaned up take all the money go back into the room with the three doors and use the door on the left okay okay oh wrong way my bad oh gosh wait this way right yeah yeah and then we go here we got it we got to do this so that we don't die from the acid this is a cloakroom sir by definition not a fitting place to seek answers however it's plain that the acid from your ordeal is eating away at your clothing and skin yeah yeah yeah i can clean your clothes for a minor consideration of five dollars yes please take the five dollars take the five dollars taking your money the cloakroom attendant cleans the acid off your clothes yay but i'm still injured okay we'll save a different thing then
Japanese, ma'am.
Yeah, now we just got to survive.
Okay, okay, okay.
Cool.
No more acid for me, thanks.
I'm full.
Examine the door.
This door seems to be locked.
There's a toga.
The doft trappings of revelry.
This toga whispers of good times past.
What?
A hat box.
empty but for the dead cockroach decaying in the corner.
These waiting room chairs appear to have been lifted from a dentist's office.
How could you tell?
Empty clothes hanger.
Okay, let's leave.
Okay.
Wait, we can kill that guy?
I think I will.
Oh.
I acquired a shot gun.
Thank you.
We got two rounds.
Uh.
Wait, put on...
Hold on, sorry.
I'm reading the guide because this part's scary.
I don't want to mess anything out.
You know?
Oh, now we can wear the toga.
Can I put it on?
Toga on me.
Man, I want to wear it.
Oh.
Oh, it's a secret.
Yeah, Steve definitely has gamer posture.
He died of natural.
Oh, he's gone!
They're so efficient here.
Shotgun shells?
Like rare gems, these shotgun shells have been secreted in the hidden room by someone who knew their value.
Whoa!
And we got a scythe!
This scythe gleams harshly beneath the...
bear bulb yoink I wanted to wear the toga oh well okay um a cracked vase is a mirror do your save files name seem like names on a music album and now we are on the second disc of an extended special edition maybe right let's save again Cool.
Let's go to the right.
How nice.
A cow.
The four eyes of this mutated cow blink disinterestly.
Wait, they're blinking?
Glistening in the firelight.
Over a dozen books on animal husbandry.
What does that mean?
Zootopia.
authored by various leading Third Reich scientists.
Hmm?
A blazing fire.
Animal.
Raising animals.
Ah, okay.
I thought we were marrying the animals.
A pair of mutated horses pulling a cart filled with rhubarb.
Stockyard mutated cat.
Why are they all mutated?
A duck.
A brass duck sticking over the edge of a shelf.
candle is still warm is there anything I can take I always forget like
disturbingly as you step over this rug you spy a brand mark seared into the fur oh my god oh my god the radio good old radio oh I think it just blinked that cow alright let's go We went this way, but let's go this way real quick.
Oh.
Well, I hope you're proud of yourself.
Killing my clientele.
Ever since the monsters invaded this level, the members have taken to dining with the Grand Puba upstairs.
Actually, I have to admit, my last few meals haven't been up to snow.
The problem is the freshness of the corpses or lack thereof.
Is this not the guy from the meat house?
The sergeant at arms always used to insist that bodies killed in the lodge be disposed of without trays and so the members would bring me their business for preparation and dissemination resident evil we need the basement it is okay it is right what's behind all this killing oh dear you're not a member are you you're an initiative forgive me i can't say another word about it can you tell me anything that might help me not really oh um just got to see visuals of your May Cafe...
Ah!
Wait, did they post it?
Nice thigh.
Sasuke oimum.
Ah!
Um...
This will take you to the...
Okay, hold on.
I'm reading the guide real quick.
Talk to the chef and kill him if you want.
Pick up a sandwich and eat it if your health is low.
Who's flushing the toilet?
A cut of meat that no ordinary butcher would have a name for.
Oh, I could take it.
Doink.
Well, I hope you're proud of yourself.
Oh, you're saying the same thing.
Ever since the...
Just kidding.
Actually, I have to admit, my last few meals haven't been up to snow.
Oh, wait.
The problem is the freshness of the corpses or lack thereof.
Cannibalism, finally!
The sergeant at arms always used to insist that bodies...
Uh, do you know a girl named Stephanie?
Sorry.
You'd need to talk to the membership director up on two.
Can you tell me anything that might help me?
Not really.
Uh, yoink.
Wait, my health is kind of bad, so we'll eat the sandwich.
Ham and cheese on rye.
Wait, can I eat it?
Right click to eat.
Oh.
Oh gosh.
God, Steve.
How do you like this?
This bottle is filled with a viscous red liquid which is clearly not anything as wholesome as ketchup okay well oh what's this what's it what's what's cooking a watched severed head never boils oh it is a man this sink is littered with dead bait this freshly removed hand still twitches reflexively grasping for salvation it's people we got it we We made it!
We made it to cannibalism!
I figured this game had to have cannibalism.
It had to, it had to.
Alright, now we can really save.
Over that.
Um...
Awesome.
Uh...
Okay.
Maybe let's go look at that plant.
I'm afraid this thing's gonna eat me.
The plant is blocking your way.
Can I cut the plant?
I don't want to shoot it.
I don't want to waste my bullets.
Give it the arm?
Yeah, right.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, wait.
The guide, hold on.
It's telling me to go back in here real second.
The cloakroom and use the light switch.
There was a light switch?
I need something.
Oh, there's a telephone.
Old-fashioned telephone.
There's a light switch somewhere?
Oh, here.
Electric switch.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Gosh, this is why a guide is...
My ears!
Holy
cow, it was scary.
Slot machines.
Some classic one-armed bandits.
Wait, can I play?
Winner!
Oh, yeah.
Pool table.
Someone scratched.
This looks like I can take it.
Riddled with teeth marks?
Who'd be biting on the pool?
And this is a baseball bat.
Batter up?
I'll take that.
Yoink.
What's lost in...
Gate.
Bruce M holds the high scores.
How much you want to bet that's like a dev?
The TV no Steve, yeah!
The picture of Morris foot sucker McGee in the cradle.
Okay.
Um.
Buckaroo.
I rip the guts.
Most kids don't see godless heathen engines on a regular basis.
And if they do, they've been...
All right.
What's in here?
Oh.
Um.
If I walk, is something gonna grab me?
There we go.
Whoa!
Okay.
What if...
I feed it?
You know?
What if I give it a little bit of a meat?
There's more to come.
that I obtained.
This bad boy.
Okay, nice.
How?
Okay, oh my gosh.
They, like, broke that rule.
I can't remember the rule right now, but for, like, movies, when you go to the left, you should enter through the right, but we went to the left and we entered through the left, so it just throws off your...
Okay, anyway.
Yeah, the 180 rule.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cans of laxo veg.
Empty.
Why would anyone want to join the lodge?
I thought it was going to be really fancy and nice in here.
I don't know why.
It needs some incentive.
What's in the trash?
The roaches are crazed by the succulent riches contained herein.
You're always fun to watch and you're very funny.
What?
Thank you.
Thanks for 10 months.
So you don't participate in the blood drive.
I guess that's true.
Wait, can we take this pipe like before?
No.
Roller.
In lieu of toilet paper, please avail yourself to the lodge's own bidet.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
The fluid leaking out from out of order toilet.
A little patience and good aim will save some trees.
What's in the bathtub?
The lodge version of an ancient Roman vomitorium.
What?
What is that?
They're empty.
Nothing.
Oh, weed killer!
This pesticide... Ah!
Wait, this is for the plant!
Okay, nice.
Anything else in here?
Can I examine... Oh, the sink?
Someone must have mistaken it for a toilet.
Of course.
I'll tell you though.
Girls bathrooms.
If you've ever thought that they might be like cleaner or anything.
They're not.
Girls bathrooms.
Like public restrooms are usually so horrible.
Thank you so much for the toilet.
Thank you.
It's not.
You would think like maybe like girls would be like so like.
I'm going to make it nice and clean.
No, they're not.
They're really gross.
My mom would tell me, it's kind of insane.
Bombatoriums were standing rooms for large clouds.
Clouds.
Crowds and buildings.
They had nothing to do with puke.
Oh, okay.
The game is just silly then.
Oh, we have to...
We have to use the other body.
Oh!
Dang it.
There is Buckaroo, right?
Buckaroo?
I didn't save.
I didn't know that I couldn't take a single step forward.
Stay tuned, Buckaroos!
All right, take that.
Run, run, run, run, run.
No, I will take it so much.
Where is that dog?
Grab it.
Grab that.
And we leave.
There's a snake in my boot.
Alright, here's your chunk of meat.
It's a bust.
Okay, nice.
Alright, let's save again.
Save.
Apparently we can eat this bubblegum if our health is low, so keep that in mind.
Alright, I think we've done everything that I've done.
I'm double checking.
We'd kill her on the plant.
Let's go.
A cleaning lady at work tells supervisors who tell us in the morning meeting that the ladies need to stop leaving toilet paper in the corner of the back.
Why did I do that?
I'm going to destroy these bathrooms, then Pito save.
Now, what does that mean?
I
didn't think I would take such a big step forward.
My bad.
Buckaroo?
Chomp, chomp, chomp.
Oh, man.
I love the...
Stay tuned, buckaroos.
Stay tuned, buckaroos!
They'd throw fireball whiskey balls.
bottles into the used box.
What is crazy?
I once worked at a mini golf place and I had to clean the bathrooms there too.
And always the ladies room was so wild.
I think maybe, I don't know if it was like a, like a, what's it called?
Because like the moms were bringing their kids in there or something and then they would just be like, I'm too busy to clean up after myself.
New lore.
Have I never told you?
A million jobs, I think.
Yeah, and stay down.
Examine the gate.
A closed gate.
Oh, wait.
Oh, we go in there.
Oh.
This is new.
Mint worked at mini golf.
it was cool it was like a themed one so it had like a really fun aesthetic i liked working there it was fun it wasn't bad it looks more alien than plant-like examine the fountain the once beautiful fountain needs a gardener the weeds have taken over oh operate the fountain okay
Okay.
Am I pixel hunting?
Oh,
wait.
Wait.
Where was that?
What was that?
I missed... Wait.
I had it.
Oh, wait.
Examine.
Ah!
Examine!
Examine the fountain key!
Oh, a key at the bottom.
of the fountain.
Oh my gosh.
Is it...
Is there a...
A keyhole somewhere?
Is there a keyhole somewhere?
I don't remember a locked door.
Fountain key.
Is it in here?
His face is killing me.
Um...
Oh, I was standing!
Wait, oh, I thought I was standing right in front of it, just kidding.
Oh, wait.
Uh...
Examine the hole!
Like, you can't even see it!
Actually, my head is blocking it, too.
So you guys wouldn't have seen it.
Ah!
We opened up a door.
Oh!
Sweet cow.
Did he get me?
Nah, we're fine.
Shisha!
You killed the cyber demon!
Why are we suddenly in like doom?
What's here?
Anything?
Oh.
Fowl smelling liquid.
Examine the rope?
Rotting piece of plywood.
What's the rope?
This rope looks dirty enough to climb!
As you grab the rope, you hear a scream.
Quickly, you climb up to investigate.
Oh, hello.
Art curator?
Welcome to the Harvest Moon Art Gallery, sir.
I'm the curator of this place.
So delighted you could come.
Um, I expect it'll be an engaging experience.
That it will, I'm afraid.
Art often forces engagement, doesn't it?
Lovely works, pastoral scenes, noble sculptures.
These are easy on the eye and mind.
But when confronted with a work of hideous form, we're forced to deal with it, even if only to dismiss it as trash.
Sadly, the most extreme works are the hardest to dismiss.
Proteskerism it works of evil.
Oh, no, we got another yapper.
Nevertheless, it's important that each individual determine his own sense of aesthetics.
I don't think this is the top hat, man.
I think I had a beard, no?
There's no way he could get rid of that.
It's not possible.
I'm just passing through.
If only it were that simple.
Well, actually, we didn't...
We could just save here again.
Okay, cool.
All right.
Let's, uh...
A very disturbing painting.
Is it?
Dark and mysterious.
Okay, that one I'll agree with.
What's it say?
Oh, no telling.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I want to see what this...
Okay.
Anyway.
Sculpture.
Sickingly offensive.
Am I missing something?
Is it...
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Oh, as the statue crashes to the floor, a small key is dropped.
You pick up the key.
Wait, did I take some damage though?
Oh, no!
We took big damage.
I tried to leave.
Dang.
Okay, well, we got a key.
Um...
Hold on, I'm gonna look at the walkthrough real quick.
Oh.
unlock the door in the gallery.
There's a door?
Oh, it says kill all the living statues.
Okay, there's more than one.
Okay, okay, okay.
Did you eat the gum?
I didn't.
Strangely calming.
Looks like it was painted with fresh blood.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, a cow!
Roughly hone in jade.
Perverse...
Perversely abstract.
Okay.
What are you seeing?
Am I just not artistically inclined, you think?
Yeah, we did just save, so...
One does not simply walk through the gallery.
Another statue?
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh, I think I wasted a boat.
Wait, this must be the door.
The door is locked.
Yeah.
This must be it.
Hat, dag!
Find the door between two ash trays There's a chest master is located.
What does that mean?
Minigolf?
Isn't that regular size?
Shut up!
Wait, was that not the key?
Hold on.
I think I was in the way.
B-17s in flight.
What is their obsession with B-17s?
Strange group of guys.
Wait, I just realized we didn't do anything with that military guy.
Was I supposed to, or...
Heavy and intimidating.
Oh!
Oh no, we're out!
We're out of bullets.
I guess I didn't need to do anything, or rather...
Oh, it just is a whole loop.
I really wasted my time.
my bullets.
That's okay, though.
B-17.
Bomber!
I did get shot by him.
His quest was to...
Actually, I guess I didn't.
It was, like, to investigate the guys at the fire...
At the firehouse, but I didn't do that.
Aw, man.
Oh.
This is where I came from?
Okay.
Uh...
What's in here?
Oh!
Hello.
Can I help you?
I'm looking for a girl.
This is a library, not a brothel.
You don't understand.
I have reason.
I hope to believe that she was brought here.
Do you know anything about that?
I'm afraid not.
I tend to stay out of lodge affairs.
I'm only in charge of the library.
oh okay well if she is here she's not been invited as a member there are no female members of the order to be sure one or two have qualified throughout our history but they're generally not of our caliber a your one though no I doubt there are any females in this building my own at least none that are extant but you're a woman I'm not a member all women are kept here for the services they gender.
Just as some jobs are beneath men, so too can certain services only be supplied by women.
No man will ever be a librarian.
If she is here, you'll find her on the third floor.
Third floor!
Which you'll have difficulty finding without my help.
Oh.
And you want something in return.
I'll give you a clue as to how to get to the third floor, but only if you'll retrieve an overdue book from one of our charter members, a Mr. Kane.
Mr. Kane.
highly regarded among the order.
I'm loath to approach him on such an embarrassing matter.
I see.
Therefore, bring me the book, and I'll help you.
How will I know which book?
Oh, you'll know it.
He's not an avid reader.
Got it.
All right.
A book, you say.
Whoa.
Okay, I'm going to save.
But I kind of...
We'll save a new save just in case.
I die.
Um...
It's probably Dojinchi.
Examine the door.
The door is locked.
The door is barred from the other side.
Wait, what's this way?
Wait, this area is huge!
Okay.
Oh.
Why does this feel like a liminal space in a way?
Oh, oh, what is this?
Oh.
Excuse me.
You can't come in right now.
I just mopped the floor.
You think just because I'm a janitor, I got no pride?
That's all I got to do all day is clean up after you rich bastards.
Take a hike before you get hurt.
All right, buddy.
You act for it.
Oh, no, I act for it.
Oh.
Actually, I didn't even try going forward anymore.
It's because I was just holding the right key and it like, it like kept the inputs.
So, um, I didn't even do anything.
Oh, the size, that's right.
We did get the size.
I forgot.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hello, it's in here.
Membership director.
Hello!
Let me see.
Oh yes, the new initiate.
I'm the lodge membership director.
What can I do for you?
Could you help me out a little?
Shortly you will run into a fellow named Mr. Kane.
Mr. Kane!
He has the strength of the truly insane.
You will need help to get past him.
They say that music hath charms to soothe the savage breast.
Breast?
Beast?
Wait.
But an appreciation of music may net you something, it will.
Breast.
Decorative swords.
Photographs of vaguely familiar strangers.
Okay.
That's what we need.
Is he in here?
I love the way he walks.
Whoa.
An ornate vine.
We got to play something nice.
Beautiful ground.
Oh, what just happened?
Oh.
I don't think I can walk.
Wait.
Oh, I think we're trapped a little.
Okay, I left.
And I can't go this way, so I'll have to go this way.
Hmm.
I wonder what he'll request.
Okay, we can only keep going this way.
I think I went this way, right?
Yes, that's the room where I got shot.
So let's go forward.
Ash tray.
A rook-shaped ash tray.
Is that blood on the door or...
Oh, he'll probably ask me.
for baby shark.
No, you know that one song that you can do with your knuckles?
The...
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
That's what I'll play.
Go in!
Hello?
Oh.
An excellent likeness in oil.
A reflection of an excellent likeness in oil.
Wait, I don't know chess.
Oh no.
An intellectual arena.
I am a chess master.
Oh, this is not the voice I expected.
Any initiate who wishes to pass this way must do so over my dead body.
Okay.
Being a civilized man, I offer my opponents a choice.
Solve my problem or fight me to the death.
Do you know how to play chess?
No.
Chess is a civilized game.
We're gonna kill him.
How sad that we must now resort to a less civilized form of conflict.
Oh, oh no!
What the hell?
I missed the cutscene.
Oh.
How did that happen?
What's he got?
I'll take that.
All right.
Why don't we take the axe too?
Checkmate.
A special memorial mirror honored...
honoring the chess master as Mr. Quengeaniality at the All-American Chess Playoffs and Swimsuit Competition.
First place trophy in the cabinet makers Union Chapter 501 Special Chess Olympics for differently able spinal injury victims.
Where does this key go to?
First place trophy in the St. Mark's Children's Hospital Burn Ward chock full of chess festival.
I got the chess key.
Maybe it's a room that... Wait, I'm on.
Oh, shoot.
Oh,
shoot.
Okay, well, I didn't say before the Chess Master, so we'll have to do that again.
One badge!
Well, we'll get to see the cutscene then, that's fine.
Oh, I got stuck here, that's right, okay.
No, no, no, no, there we go.
Nah.
Chess.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, that's literally it!
Now I don't feel like we missed some.
much then chase checkmate all right this is gnarly what
a cut scene honestly wait actually i want to do a different one no no different one different one checkmate i
wonder if i can kill this guy
Oh, oh, he's beefy.
Oh, he's beefy.
Oh, he's really beefy.
I think we might just die.
I got him.
Searching the body, you find a book.
It really is Doom Salons.
Who is this?
Did I- I got the book?
Wait, that was Kane!
Ah, Mr. Kane's sole material possession since the death of his brother.
Oh!
I did it!
Something else was...
Wait, what did they say about Kane?
The... the, uh...
Anyone else sad that the fight was better animated than what I...
Yeah, it's something about music.
Okay.
Who needs music?
Um...
Okay.
Um, can I go this way?
No.
Alright, well we got the book for the librarian, I guess.
Um...
Let's go back to...
Uh...
Not the janitor.
No, not the janitor.
This door, is this the chest door?
This is the wrong key.
Um...
Puzzler for nerds!
Real men swing their sides!
Yeah!
Uh...
Do we have another option?
I like this room.
I don't think I can get to him, though.
I think I tried before, and I couldn't.
So let's just go back to the librarian, I guess.
I think I'm doing things a little out of order from what the guide is saying.
Oh, wait.
Was it here?
Wait, where am I?
I'm lost.
Oh, no.
Okay, I'm not lost.
It's right here.
I have...
This book was inside him.
Ah, you've returned the book I see.
Yep.
Thank you, young man.
Feel free to look around the library for anything that interests you.
Oh.
You told me you'd help me get to the third floor.
Yeah.
Ah, yes.
You'll need a special key, which is in the keeping of our resident chess master.
Oh, I got it!
Here is your clue.
Along with the positions of his pieces, the chess master holds the key to the third level, always in his thoughts.
That's the clue?
Oops, a sequence broke.
I'll write it down for you so that you won't forget.
If you don't find this key, I'm afraid you'll never make it any further.
Yeah, but where do I use it?
Good luck.
Oh.
Thanks.
Okay.
Oh.
Can I help you?
I'm looking for a girl.
Okay, never mind.
This is all Same.
Uh, What do you mean, X?
Oh, I see.
You're the new initiate.
If she is here, you'll find... Okay, let's leave.
Okay, well, always in his thoughts.
The key was in his brain?
Easy peasy.
Um...
Uh...
I know I love the way he walks when he's holding the weapons.
fighting do i use maybe uh the key on the okay hold on have you seen the over the garden wall pilot episode of read the comics i have seen the pilot i did not read the comics
let's just save again with kim time to fight the janitor you think i can do it hold on let's try the key on the piano real quick well that didn't work oh gosh he's such a he's got such an attitude well that didn't work okay let's go fight the janitor I suppose
the piano already has keys what does the guide say the guide says to shoot the janitor so We're just gonna have to attempt
Excuse me You can't come in right now I just You think Alright but Ah See I can't even get close to him
Am I soft locked maybe Uh oh Oh no
Yeah I already knew that's why you shoot I was just...
I told you guys already.
Oh, no.
There's a cheat if you want to get ammo.
Is there?
It says somewhere that there's a way to get...
Wait, operate the...
Operate the two ash trays.
Wait, wait, we can get some shotgun from the ash trays, apparently.
Uh...
Wait, hold on.
Hopefully there's enough.
Found a shotgun shell.
How many were there?
Wait, why aren't they...
I only have two, though.
The guide says you need three.
Let's try.
You can read.
him it's rng what excuse me you can't hey buddy give me a break will you keep up the floor you think just all right
grabbing the nail gun you added to your inventory hoping it will come in handy oh
my gosh
lucky ducky
Okay, wait, um, but we don't have anything else.
Does this have ammo?
Oh, it does.
Okay, we'll save it then.
We'll save it.
We'll just use the scythe for now.
We'll keep with the scythe.
What is this thing?
The curtain.
Melodrama is involving the brutal murder of men by ungrateful suffragettes?
with the lodge membership.
What?
I don't see anything else is called.
What a lovely little dining hall.
The door is locked.
It must be this key.
Yeah!
Women.
Oh!
grabbing the chainsaw you add it to your inventory hoping it will come in handy you also find a cupid doll and something that looks like a key
this projector is broken so you're unable to screen the film which happens to be a light holiday children's classic monkey boy goes ape shit with the chainsaw i'm not gonna examine that i'm scared wait there's so many things dangerous in here don't say that this cake is half eaten say that this cake is Spattered with brain matter.
Either way, don't eat it.
Wait.
Is my health...
Oh no!
Guys, we're not looking so good.
We need health stat.
Uh-oh.
Is there anything over here?
No.
Okay, I'm guessing the cutie.
But it goes more than just pop.
Eat some cake.
We won't let us!
Here, actually, we'll save a new one.
Clown.
Whoops.
Whatever.
Clowning.
Rounding.
Okay.
Eat the brain.
It won't let me in.
The game hates me.
Brown stands on the outside of this jack-in-the-box suggests you don't want what's packed inside to come spread out.
Are you sure?
What's the tank?
Happy guy.
Blood splattered movie screen.
So now is that Cupid key?
The thing to open the doors.
The double doors.
Dummy.
Steve is so stupid sometimes.
By sometimes I mean all the time.
I'm gonna have to go get some...
Some, what's it called soon for me, though?
The Cupid doll.
Uh, some more water.
Whoa!
A flag on a pole.
Oh, I could take it.
Can I take this one?
Okay.
I don't know why I just grabbed these.
How much left of the game?
We're on level 2, we have level 3 left, and then the game is over.
So maybe, I don't know, like an hour-ish or so?
Who knows?
Okay, we're backstage.
Yeah, not much left.
Mm-hmm.
A wooden plank.
Non-functional prop kitchen.
Lunchbox?
Range Rider lunchbox with feed bag accessories.
sandwich wait perfect that's the that's a nail gun shotgun where's my sandwich sandwich oh yeah awesome we needed that
we'll save over clowning around and okay yeah um I
guess we go this way
there's a door windmill after being a abducted by aliens and subjected to unspeakable degradations.
This windmill is now the only suitable for a life in the theater.
Wait, what?
What happened to the windmill?
Oh my gosh.
Can you come over here?
Standard type C fire extinguisher.
Okay.
Complementary coffin nails.
Nice!
Have another, dear.
Taste great.
See how it should- Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh, my chainsaw, yeah.
I should equip it.
Wait, is there anything in here?
Lighter fluid.
A can full of lighter fluid.
I'll take that.
Essential theatrical equipment.
Costumes.
Okay.
Pick up the lighter next to the sofa.
Wait, did I miss something?
Operate the masks on the wall.
Eh?
Oh, these!
Examine the mask.
Two masks hanging on the wall.
Oh!
What?
Did they...
Was I supposed to grab anything here?
Is it something about...
I guess it meant the lighter fluid.
looking at the guide oh I saw it said pick up the plank oh it did thank you thank you thank you um am
I supposed to make this one sad oh okay I'm
a genius just What is this game?
It looks cool.
Kiyote!
It's a game!
I feel like I should have used not the scythe on the zombie.
Oh well.
Hmm.
1000 IQ.
That's mean.
We're solving that.
Totally on purpose.
Sam in the washers, blood red water swirls, what is the lodge so weird?
My wife wants to marry you, stay away from my wife, come here wife, our wife.
What is this?
What else we got?
Oh, these look like Stephanie's clothes!
Wait, is Stephanie not dead?
Oh my gosh.
Uh-oh.
That doesn't sound good.
Wait.
That doesn't sound good at all.
Wait a second.
Uh, power fuse box.
Uh-oh.
Uh.
Oh, geez.
Wait.
Uh, oh gosh.
Um, pipe.
Pick up the pipe.
What do I need this for?
Wrench.
Pick up the wrench?
What do I need this for?
Uh, battery?
The battery's dead?
Uh, oh gosh.
pipe pick up the pipe well that didn't work no put it in me more pipe okay uh it won't yeah let's go back to the gauge this thing it won't i can't look at it actually um where do they go the pipes
Where do they go?
Am I blind?
Hard to see?
Oh, is it here?
Wait.
I can't see it.
I don't know where it is.
Where the steam is coming out.
Here.
Wait.
Broken pipe!
This pipe has a rusted hole.
How do I fix it?
On...
Okay, that didn't fix it.
Um...
Wait, what?
Well, apparently you need to use the wrench on the broken pipe.
Damn it.
Wait, where's the broken pipe?
Where'd it go?
Okay, there it is.
Oh, and then I put in the new one?
Pipe is too short.
I maybe I maybe I put them together aha okay okay okay okay oh man
oopsie oops okay all right well that gave me a good amount of time to figure that out oh geez okay 1000 IQ totally okay
Just it, it's nothing.
Stephanie's clothes.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to click on me.
Oh, get me out of there.
Okay, so we go, go, go, go.
We grab the pipe.
Grab it.
Take it.
Put it in my pocket.
Grab the wrench.
We'll do the wrench now.
Wrench on.
Oh, that's the chainsaw.
Turn it off.
What did I use?
Oh, wrench on.
The...
Oh, it's so hard to see.
Oh, my gosh.
Where is it?
Oh, broken pipe.
Right there.
Okay.
Oops.
And then we run.
Okay.
Smarty pants over here.
Grab it.
Combine it.
Okay.
I'm not quite sure how this works, but sure.
And then we go back.
Uh.
Okay.
Um.
Well, that didn't work.
Okay.
Uh, bypass back.
Well, that didn't work.
Eh?
Oh, wait.
Where do I put this now?
Okay.
Oof.
A key.
Boiler room key.
I don't want to do that again.
So we're going to save the game.
Sheeshaw.
Okay.
1000 IQ indeed.
Yes indeedy.
Boiler room key?
This one.
Well that didn't work.
Oh.
It didn't?
The door's...
Did I...
Oh, there we go.
Again.
Okay, I'm gonna change my weapon.
I also wanted to say... Maybe the chainsaw.
Oh, it also... Okay.
Interesting.
I'm gonna try the nail gun.
This guy is tough?
No way, really?
Okay.
Let's try the nail gun.
Chainsaw too tiny.
Oh, whoops.
I forgot.
I needed to unlock it.
Oh, I pressed...
I pressed right click instead of left click.
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Tough my booty.
We got him good.
The turbines scream in a high-pitched wine.
Where the heck are we?
Whoa.
These are Zumbini sound effects.
I'm examining the lava.
The hot molten lava has melted this section of the floor okay wait can I use my my plank oh I need another one wait wait it's on fire uh-oh I think that's the sound of it burning
I think I have to reload
I think we have to go back out and uh...
Oh man.
Use it!
What do you mean?
Oh man!
I'm gone.
No ice.
Alright, save.
I think we can read okay wait so I was gonna say we can read fill our ammo at that vending machine for this gun but I need to find another wooden plank somewhere did you guys see one the door is locked wait oh wait wait wait wait oh oh am I screwed wait wait
the key
Like the key to...
This key?
Will this work?
I don't.
This is how I'm feeling right now.
Oh my god, I only grabbed one plank.
How far back do I have to load?
Clowning around in?
Gahew!
I got them.
Oh my gosh, I have to do that stinking puzzle all over again.
Oh my gosh.
But you know what?
This time, I didn't get hurt.
Complementary coffin nails.
Oh, it didn't give me more.
Well, you know what?
That's fine.
There's three.
Okay, there's three.
Thank you.
We gotta go find one more then.
Naria, thank you so much for the redirect.
Thank you.
Welcome, welcome.
Where's the third one at?
Oh, this one.
Thank you, guys.
I'll bring it back.
Thank you.
I can't see I have to do the IQ.
Thank you, guys.
Oh, wait.
I figured it out.
There I go, thank you for the fine gift to take up a yon-yon, thank you.
Alright, hold on, let's save real quick.
Maybe I shouldn't have used.
We'll just save over 1000 IQ since it's already soft locked.
Maybe I shouldn't have used the nail gun on.
But it's fine, it's fine, whatever.
I'm gonna put it away though in case I accidentally use it again.
Okay.
No, well thank you.
Poffing nails or cigarettes.
Oh!
Okay, before I go...
Actually, I'm gonna leave this room because the sound is annoying.
Before I...
Go in there, I'm gonna get something to drink real quick.
I will be right back.
You guys, it's so funny.
I've been trying to sneeze all stream.
My nose has been so icky.
As soon as I walk out the door, two sneezes.
Two of them.
Ouch, ouch.
Alrighty.
I also got a little snack.
It's cheese and nuts.
Yummy.
Alright, let's go do this one really annoying puzzle.
Puzzoon tight.
Nankashim.
Okay.
Run, run!
I got the third plank, no?
I'll double check.
Yeah, I got three planks.
We're good, we're good.
Pick up!
I guess I don't need to put it in my inventory.
Whatever.
Whatever, it's fine.
Oh wait, uh...
Turn the bell!
On the pipe!
Wait, where do I put it?
There we go.
Okay.
Go grab the other pipes.
Grab it!
Oh my gosh.
I hate him so much sometimes.
Combine!
Okay.
Ew!
Yippee!
Okay.
We've avoided the soft lock.
Equip nail gun.
Save game.
Oh, I should have saved it after I unlocked it, but whatever.
Okay.
Why do you say that?
It's literally what you're supposed to do.
Oh, I have just two left.
Okay.
like he's being so smart with me
we've managed to avoid soft locking
okay why would you walk into the water
1000 IQ
what he's gonna say it again oh man Damn it.
Well that didn't work.
Damn it.
I don't understand why it doesn't work.
Okay now we're gonna save.
Since we're already committed to this save run, we'll just, you know.
Okay.
Obviously, I know that this is, like, going to be a timed thing.
So...
Okay, and next one.
Run!
I don't know how this works, but sure.
Yeah!
Finally another brood!
Wait, what?
What was the third one?
What was the third plank?
What?
Oh, gosh.
Uh.
Oh, I know.
I know what to do.
I know what to do here.
I can tell.
Aha!
I know what to do.
The remains of a less fortunate initiate.
Limestone stalagmite.
Can I leave now?
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha!
Why'd you pick up those two flags?
Ragbos.
For this reason and this reason alone.
Damn.
I really...
That was like...
I think I could put that on my resume.
Thanks.
Thanks quickly on her feet.
Oh, hello.
Whoa.
I thought I was gonna die.
I look like I'm dying.
Can carry two flagpoles.
Okay.
Hmm.
We go up.
I'm scared to save because I took a lot of damage, but I will save a new save.
Knocking on death's door.
Oop.
Alright, here we go.
Up to the fourth floor!
Level three, just kidding.
I'm in third floor!
Can't count!
You hear a familiar scream quickly, you climb up to investigate.
When you say you want us to have cool stuff to say about you, that now top of the list!
Yeah, my Yoshi.
She can't count to three.
Damn!
Let's go.
I could use a snack.
The door is locked from the other side.
Oh my gosh, we're at the last level, you guys.
We're so close to the game.
Wait, can I have one of those?
This is the temple of the mystery of abstinence.
Do not eat of the food or you will be punished.
All within are hereby bound to a vow of abstinence.
I thought that was...
I thought that was not with food.
Operate the hamburger.
Wait, he's eating it, though!
What if I do it?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wait.
Did I get my health back?
Mm-hmm.
I think I'm going to reload.
Ugh.
Um, I don't want to lose on my goal this way.
Um...
Pretentious and preachy.
This is the...
Examine door.
What about this one?
It's locked.
There's a plant.
This is the temple of the...
What am I supposed to do then?
Just wait here?
Can I kill him with the chainsaw?
I want...
The burger though.
So unfair.
Operate hamburger.
I'll take one take one
The central mystery is thus those who advocate abstinence are those who possess the most It is to their advantage that you obey not to yours The meek shall inherit the earth when the strong are finished with it The advance initiate and remember what you have learned Oh
You miss every shot you can't don't take,
buddy.
Um, literal stormtrooper aim.
Why do you...
Why do you look at me like that?
Wait a second!
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna save here.
Will I ever get out of here?
Maybe I do just have to nail gun through it.
but ah ah whatever oh okay give me that this is the temple of the
oh wait i want to see his face again so funny it is to their advantage that you obey not to yours the meek shall inherit the earth when the strong are finished with it advance initiate and remember what you have learned
so funny
oh I was oh my gosh you guys I was pressing right click I was just I'm so sorry I'm actually an idiot I was not shooting with it I was pressing I was that was my bad that was actually my bad I was right clicking to okay my bad my bad okay eat shut up the central mystery is I love his face.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot the ammo.
Yeah, but he still killed me.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, my God.
We'll take this.
Oh, gosh.
I think I'm in trouble, guys.
Shut up.
I don't care.
Oh my god.
How many times do I have to see this?
Why am I not shooting?
What?
I was clicking this time for me, though.
Oh!
Why was I not shooting?
I clicked so many times.
Out of range.
No, I clicked when it was green.
Also, you can just click and you should be able to shoot.
You don't have to like actually be on them.
You lost on purpose to see that guy's face again.
I'm sick of it!
I don't care about your message!
Oh, oh, oops.
I have
to reload the gun.
I don't know I don't think so it's getting worse here I'll check though you know what I made it when I only use this guy so let's just do that this is the temp oh my god I'm such an idiot stop shooting up
you know what fine I'm not even gonna touch Watch it.
I don't care.
Eat your stupid burgers.
This is the...
I'm clicking.
I'm clicking right now, you guys.
Oh, finally.
I'm clicking.
What the hell?
The system of victory is thus.
Those who advocate abstinence are those who possess the most.
It is to their advantage that you obey.
Ah!
Oh, you can't, though.
I can't with this.
Oh,
no, I didn't mean to do that.
I do need help.
I hate this part!
Why am I
gonna...
Why is the game being so stinky to me?
Are you sure you didn't forget the controls when you thought you were out of ammo?
Oh, yeah.
Oh yeah, Scythe.
Totally known for having ammo.
Yeah.
The most famous weapon of choice that is known for having ammo.
The Scythe.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wesker from AliExpress.
Who that?
Is that a Resident Evil guy?
Well, if you're Ruby.
I don't know why the game is being so stinky all of a sudden, though.
I mean, when it's my fault, I, you know, I say it's my fault, but I don't know why.
Okay, I'm just going to let the...
Okay, I'm reading the guide.
The guide says let the dude eat the burgers and then he kill him.
But, like, shut up.
I don't care.
I'll switch to the nail gun.
I feel like we did well with the chainsaw.
Well, let him eat his burgers, and then this guy leaves, apparently.
Finish your burgers, Mr. Presley.
You obey well, Initiate.
Better than your brethren.
They have eaten and grown stronger for it.
As promised, I will not punish you for your obedience.
But they will.
Oh my god!
Hello?
Once again, the game is not...
I'm...
trying to play the game and it's not letting me oh
no why okay
maybe if i move closer this is the temple of maybe if i'm like not in the i don't know maybe restart the game we'll see we'll see
oh my god emoji
you obey well initiative please please oh
I'm actually getting tilted a little bit.
I just want to progress.
I'll try a different weapon.
I don't know.
This is the...
I don't think restarting the game is going to do anything, you guys.
Let me just try!
Yeah!
You obey well and...
I'll
quit.
I'll redraw.
Why?
Oh my god, GOG just said, rate this game.
You're really...
Yeah.
I'll rate it.
Alright, let's see.
Maybe something will change.
Oh.
Stop spamming.
I don't even have a rocket launcher.
Why would you spam that if I don't have it?
Why?
Why would you do that?
Why would you spam something I don't have?
Why?
Why would you do that?
Do you have the Scythe rocket launcher?
Oh, maybe.
To try Ice Monkey?
Oh my gosh guys, we have to start all the way from the beginning.
Just kidding.
Wouldn't it be cool if it did though?
Oh, oh.
Control.
Oh my gosh, I got a control F4.
There we go.
Oh, control F4.
Okay.
Try moving diagonally.
Let's try again.
Whoops.
Let's try.
Try again.
I'm clicking.
It's still not working.
It's still not working, you guys.
I was spam clicking.
I feel like I'm getting soft locked because the game mechanics are so bad.
If there is a cheat, like please tell me.
I don't know what you guys are telling me to use cheats, but I don't know what they are at all.
The central mystery is thus.
Okay.
Wait, can I eat the burger?
You eat the hamburgers.
I ate all of them.
Actually, yeah, we'll just...
We'll just...
This one.
Just save.
Just...
I don't want to ever see it again.
And some mothers complain that their children don't come to see them.
Mommy, you're so good.
You're so good.
This is the mystery.
Mommy, you're so good.
Cannibalism!
motherhood is fulfilling when in reality it's draining i see what you mean oh you don't know the half of it ew guys from the start children are parasites you're so good you're so good that's what you've got to understand this is why we killed jimmy james yeah you're very wonderful the hamburger was our nightmares.
Mmm,
mommy, you're so good.
Mmm, mommy, you're so good.
You're so good.
My children are better at it than most.
Is that the bliss of motherhood?
That's the mystery.
needs more greedy little mouths to feed children suck the life out of society they have to be protected and nurtured everything has to be childproof I'm glad I ate a hamburger for lunch sadly they'll suck the life out of you too mommy you're so good you're so good oh shoot oh my god wait wait wait wait kid
Come here, come here.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, I think I have to use the scythe this time.
Yeah!
Maybe you're so good.
You're so good.
Yeah!
Are you okay?
I can't talk to her anymore.
Okay, anyway.
Oh, whoa.
Welcome to the temple of the mystery of religion.
The temporary...
Wait, the temporary...
Wait, the temple of the mystery?
Those who preach love and mercy in God's name are often those who call for the death of heathens.
you believe in god my son um sure you are wise his mercy anoints us all and where doth he dwell the lord um and all of us oh i lied not just kidding But we shall open your eyes.
Even if we must shut down first.
What are you gonna do to me?
Oh.
Oh gosh, look at you.
Try?
Yeah, come here.
Oh.
Uh.
Examine the box.
These are...
There's...
Symbol...
Recepticles are symbolic of the box.
the promise of ultimate fulfillment um oh whoa why is why are we in the jungle now
a rotting remains of two children oh no a metal this poor woman has been viciously disemboweled uh where do i go Oh, this way?
What do you want here?
I'm just passing through.
You think it's that simple, huh?
Just passing through?
His voice does not suit him.
My family was just sitting around.
And look what it got them.
What is this?
The temple of the mystery of morality.
Okay.
My country paid me to kill.
And then when I came home, I was out of a job.
They expected me to stop.
Cold turkey?
Is that what they wanted?
A paycheck today, jail cell tomorrow?
Am I a criminal or an entrepreneur?
Hey, let's find out.
Might not have to fight you too.
All right, come here.
I'm too good with this sight, man.
A bloody corpse.
A nice lamp.
Anyway, there was a door over here.
Oh, hello.
Welcome to the Temple of the Mystery of Flesh, Steven.
Oh my god!
Have a bite!
Why are you here?
Mr. Potsdam!
The mystery is this.
Sometimes you have to lose some meat to get some meat.
They wouldn't let me in until I demonstrated my worthiness.
My invitation came after I buried Karen alive.
That showed initiative.
And her spinal cord was your ticket in, right?
Yes, but to be initiated into the mysteries of the harvest.
He got in!
I had to do one last thing.
Oh, no.
I left them into the house and into Stephanie's bedroom.
You do that to your own daughter?
Sometimes you have to sacrifice meat to gain meat the order taught me that.
Oh my god, Mr. Potsdam.
Now I am a butcher.
You should have gotten your dad to hire me on.
That way, I can't wait to kill this guy.
Prime cut.
Come here.
Oh.
I should have been saving.
Sorry, guys.
It's fine.
I have to go through these again.
They're not so bad.
Where are you going?
Where are you going, buddy?
I don't think I have.
I think I can only use this, though.
What do I do with this Cupid doll?
Wait, I have nails.
Nails on the nail.
Well, that didn't work.
Okay, just kidding.
We have nails for no reason.
reason I guess needed a sensor for that my bad come here wish I could just leave
oh I have one left do I have any bullets no dang I do have like a baseball bat We'll use the size though.
Here we go.
Kiwawa!
Thank you for the re-direct!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, he's good.
Oh shoot, I died.
Hi KFP!
I'm playing a really weird game.
Wait, when did I last save?
Oh, I saved that there.
I mean, you're so good.
You're so good.
That's fine, that's fine.
Ignore.
Oh no, I have to do this again.
Wait, I know the answers.
I know the answers.
Yes.
You are one.
He's in heaven.
Indeed!
Any other response would be blasphemous.
Thank you!
Answer me this.
If the word be with you.
Does the Lord bounce on a spring?
Or frolic with the wombats?
the wombat he's frolicing with them yes yeah thank you guys so much for all the gifted thank you and he is their shepherd answer thus if thou be virtuous does god almighty herd them with his staff or with special imported wombat herding equipment um take the staff naturally god being almighty have no need to import anything no yeah exactly okay sure i asked the one final question okay which is only known to those amongst the ranks of the save the is god a jar of strawberry preserves a size 12 sneaker a foot-long hoagie expense-paid trip to Brazil or a new car?
Brazil.
Why'd they sign up to Brazil?
Why?
I feel like I have to pick Brazil because I literally lamented about it yesterday.
You are correct!
Pass in peace, brother.
Oh my god.
Door is locked.
No stinking way.
I'm so angry right now.
My god.
Brazil!
Don't mind the dead people.
I'm just...
Oh, this...
Oh, uh, what, uh, you killed your family?
Oh.
My country pays me to kill.
And no one- Okay, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Oh my gosh.
Ow, ow.
Please.
I can't take the lamp.
I wish they gave you anything for the healing or anything.
Okay.
Mint is some kind of prophet.
Oh, wait.
I forgot to save.
Oh, shoot.
Mr. My bad.
uh was that her on the bed or is she alive sorry that's not my department now i'm a butcher okay okay he walks over there so i'm gonna save a new one
you know what this can also be called saved pepperoni i think it's also it also is uh it works here okay this guy is kind of tough though I have nothing else I have one on the one nail Okay But that's all I got I just have to be I just have to be good I have no other No bullets
Oh my gosh
I'm gonna die He's gonna kill me Oh,
he's gonna kill me.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't, like, run away after I...
He's tough in melee.
I don't...
Okay, guys.
Is that a box of shotgun shells as your second inventory item?
No.
It's a librarian's clue.
This is shotgun shells.
Oh, man.
Why doesn't it work?
Why would it work?
Why won't the nails work on the nail gun?
I don't get it.
There's a refill for all guns in the jungle hut.
There is?
Wait, should I reload?
Wait, what did I...
No, I was right clicking them, yeah.
This doesn't work.
work yeah I know okay well I think I'm gonna die here not gonna lie in the hut there was
where empty cardboard box cardboard box gas can oh wait you filled your oh okay I filled my thing up oh okay awesome awesome awesome okay I filled up can, empty can, empty can.
I at least have my chainsaw.
A pack of chainsaw.
There's like nothing else in here, though.
Operate the can.
Operate the box.
I found shells!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, awesome.
Awesome, awesome.
Save.
Oh, whoever told me that thing Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Probably save the run.
You probably save the run.
I would have had to use cheats and I don't even know how to use those.
Oh, and I feel refreshed.
Oh, wait.
Sorry, I'm going to save again because I just realized that that saves or that gave me more health.
Yeah.
Okay, we'll save the gun for Peploni, man.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Okay, come here.
I don't even think I took damage.
Look at that face.
That's of a fresh young man.
Clean.
That was so clean.
We'll save over pepperoni.
Oh, wait.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah.
Blah.
Oh!
He's actually coming towards me this time!
Door is locked from the other side.
Let's go!
This one is called Salamic.
I don't know why sometimes it does caps, but my caps lock is not on.
Okay!
Onwards!
Oh!
Hello, handsome.
Looking for a good time and a good time.
a reasonable price
I'd love to get it on with the ladies all right that'd be $200 oh wait I think I have that here it is 200 bucks all right honey one of the wait should I be hold on I'm gonna get it
sorry I
okay I thought it was her boobs thanks for stopping by stud you shouldn't have picked crystal though She hasn't been feeling well.
I'd be sure to get to a doctor if I were you.
These diseases can help.
Sorry, I don't even want to look at that myself.
Um.
I hated that.
Maybe she's a zombie.
So wait, was that a zombie?
What's that?
Mirror.
A hand mirror.
I'll take it.
Oh.
Whoa.
Okay, we could just go.
Oh my gosh, it's a good thing I stole all that money!
Or maybe not.
Honestly, I'm not quite... Wait.
Okay, let's go.
Welcome to the temple of beauty.
And am I not beautiful, O man?
Look at my hair.
Black as a moonless night.
Oh.
Look into my eyes.
Am I taking damage?
Wait, am I taking damage now for real?
Look at my complexion.
Pale white and glistening.
Um...
You're not that hot.
Get over it, Toots.
You bastard!
You feel the pain?
Oh, no!
Okay, I'm gonna load my save.
Well, it was worth it so we could see what happened, I suppose.
What was her name?
Christina!
No way.
Scorn mixed with desire.
That's our lot.
Such is the mystery of lust.
So often the instruments of lust as all instruments of higher pleasure are condemned as frequently as they are sought after.
I'd go on about the hypocrisy of a hedophobic society, but I think I'd rather just kill me a man.
Oh.
Okay.
See ya.
Oh, I forgot to save.
That's okay.
Um, I want to see if you're incredibly beautiful.
How much?
Oh, what do you mean what else?
Your lips are like cherries.
And what else?
silk oh you're a little vain huh you insult my beauty oh the hand mirror
sorry guys i forgot to pick up the mirror i did it the first time i forgot this time so sorry ha hello handsome hello sure all right that'll be reasonable price.
You're saying my girls aren't worth a lousy 200 bucks?
You men are all the same.
Such is the mystery of lust.
It's because her body like covered it, you know.
Pick it up, put it in my pocket, and save the game.
Oh, salami.
Okay.
Next room.
I wonder if I give her the mirror, what would happen?
You...
I love the way she walks.
She kind of looks like me.
Why are her hands like that?
Wait, is this the right way?
Wait.
Yeah, I was wondering if the mirror works on her.
Yeah, oh well.
Why are... Wait.
Why are her hands like that?
You can use the mirror on her, but you don't have to.
I think I've noticed that about this game a little bit is they give you multiple options.
It's kind of fun.
Welcome, initiate, to the temple of the mystery of pain.
The mystery is thus.
The simple manipulation of nerves may break one man and yet leave another.
It's getting a little creepy.
Crazy.
I mean, the game has already been so strange.
Although the body functions according to the tenets of science, the invocation of pain is an art.
Now it's getting crazy.
That's true.
Mmm, mummy, you're so good.
Mmm, mummy.
You're so good.
With the different applications.
Everybody's just a yopper.
I'm obsessed with these like two second cutscenes.
Ah!
Otherwise, I'll have to teach you the lesson.
Oh!
Oh no!
Oh, okay.
I killed him.
A syringe marked vaccine.
No, use it on me.
Put it in my inventory.
There we go.
Why is it just like...
You got doing like the little nervous pee or the...
Like the...
You have the pee shuffle?
Inquisitor.
Okay.
Um...
The other club is two blocks down the road.
Oh, thank you so much for the five gift it.
Thank you.
No.
Welcome to the temple of the mystery.
No, it's What's his name?
What mystery is there in charity?
Wait, it's...
It's...
Oh, gosh.
The mystery is the...
It's the...
What's his...
It's Loomish!
...for in any charitable exchange, one must take from another.
And one has always left the poor.
Nah, I'm gonna kill Loomish.
Um...
The giver is not poorer.
He receives a great feeling from giving.
A feeling?
Discouraging answer, Initiate.
That's fine.
I'm going to kill you anyway.
Though I am needy.
I do not consider myself to pay so much as a...
They shouldn't have made him this guy.
It makes me want to kill him.
Give me something.
Go to hell!
I'm a taker, Initiate.
Allow me to take you there.
Whoa.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh my God, the way they explode.
Yeah.
Yeah, kill them, kill them.
Kill them all.
We're literally, how much longer is there?
My goodness.
Oh, what is this?
This is the temple of the mystery of mercy.
Okay.
You're just in time.
time for our little retirement ceremony as part of your initiation will be required to execute them that's how old people the old people are killed oh my god should be pretty easy but by retiring them will advance yourself hold they're begging for mercy do you grant it So silly.
I'll grant them mercy.
And unfortunately, the decision.
The loss is the mystery of mercy.
Life is a competition.
They were so...
Why are they like...
If they...
Why are we so small?
When you extend your support, you have to...
They come...
On their knees, they come up to my chin.
Ah!
Wait!
Oh gosh.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I find an ancient sword.
Oh, my bad.
Let's slip up the finger.
Oopsie.
Oops.
Whoopsie-poopsy.
Wait, I...
Oh, I can use it.
Um, anyway.
Yeah, I did take a lot of damage because I was...
I took a lot of damage from him.
because i was um i was like drinking my tea so sorry
guys hold on i i swallowed my tea wrong
oh my god okay anyway oh
i'll make a separate save oh my gosh
No witnesses.
Wait, witnessing.
You know what, fine.
It's whatever.
I don't know why I wrote that.
Oh.
Um.
What the?
Oh!
Oops.
Um.
Maybe I have to shoot him too.
Wait, I don't...
Wait.
Oh, I do have more ammo.
Oh, it's a circle.
Wait.
Oh, no!
I have to go all the way back through.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, excuse me.
Sorry.
This is so awkward.
Okay, everybody, please don't.
So sorry.
My gosh, please excuse me.
This is so embarrassing.
It's just so yeah, okay.
It's this way anyway
Uh-oh guys, I think I actually need to redo that old man fight Because I think I took too much damage
Wait Okay.
La la la.
Oh, oops.
I didn't mean to click on me.
Um...
Are you crazy for good at?
Clean!
Wait, hold on.
Let me double check when my thing was.
Did I say 10 or 11?
Oops.
Okay, 11.
Good.
I gave myself plenty of time.
Okay.
Alright, let's save.
Kill Demal.
Anyway, onwards.
Oh, yeah, I did get the sword.
Yeah.
I think...
I don't know if it worked, though.
Okay.
Whoa,
that was kind of cool.
I like that one.
Wait.
That was kind of cool.
We'll go over the no witnesses.
Cool.
um oh okay welcome to the inner sanctum big guy is everybody part of the lodge and we just didn't know you will address me as vice muck hero second in command to the grand muck he of the fess and buffalo helm the secret handshake the funny passwords big guy given that my role has always been Harvest is one big classroom.
I can't wait to kill this guy too.
You'll have to kill me to find out what he means, big guy.
Big guy.
He just fell apart.
This is always a great moment when the initiate passes over the threshold and becomes a brother.
I believe you have something for her.
I do?
The Cupid doll.
Ring the bell and...
Or is it?
Win the lovely lady as your prize.
Enough games.
Agreed.
What?
Oh!
Stephanie!
Each time you climb,
but you always hurt the ones you love.
Oh yeah!
I don't know if this game was serious.
Is that all you require?
What did I have?
I want an explanation.
Of course you do.
There are such things as monsters.
And yet, you've killed monsters.
Everything in the harvest is just slightly askew.
This is because, as advanced as our technology is, we cannot make the Sim any better than this.
Subjects subconscious always warms it to you're always a kidder man Jellybee thank you
Sam This is nothing more than a virtual reality Where's the matrix?
To test potential members Having successfully completed the program you have a earned the right to become a harvester oh my gosh wait what the hell is a harvester
that grips the knife that stabs the ones who move amid the crop the right hand and harvest
you're talking about people
again and again and again I believe the technical term is serial killer.
The harvester seek to perpetuate terror and discord for our own purposes.
We do this through the random utility of murder and we persevere through our recruitment of initiates like yourself.
I love that that's the technical term.
So there's just a...
want me to become a serial killer there's just um there's just a group of wait i think i belong here i've played oblivion reality has been engineered to break down the s3 program to desensitize you to violence now you may become a harvester and re-enter i told you it's the gateway prank or stay and spend the rest of your life first you scratch a car then you do arson then you become a serial killer what is the real serial prankster right now you are suspended in a sensory deprivation tank wired to a vr tank oh my god do you think we could go to harvester terminate your life support in vr chat those last minutes however will seem like a lifetime lived in harvest you will marry stephanie and die peacefully of old age
you're presuming a lot aside from you she is the only real person in harvest Suspended.
Oh, Harvest.
Sorry, I'm at Harvest.
Yeah.
Jacked in just as you are.
I assume you'll want to spend time together.
If I stay.
Of course, having completed your ordeal, you may leave with her as you intended and enjoy your victory.
Why does he look so sad?
join us.
The cost of exiting the lodge is the same as the cost of entering the lodge.
A skull and spinal cord.
The finger.
Oh my god.
Ma'am?
You couldn't.
He's so small.
These harvesters.
through this torture to give them a taste for killing the way to beat them is to deny them to live out your life here with me do we become a serial killer or do we get the hot girl didn't you hear what he said I do exist if you kill me here I'll die for real if you die in the game you die in real life because I'm real
What's a murder without pain and terror to
her brains?
And then for the plug, you will be a murderer.
It's so small.
So what will it be?
Life in harvest or life as a harvester.
Wait, I'd have to live here?
Well, please don't make me...
Oh God, please, wait, don't make me...
Don't...
Kill Stephanie!
Mary Stephanie!
Okay, good, I can save.
Okay, we'll do both.
I don't want to live in Harvest, though.
Hum...
Serial Killer...
Or Hot Girl.
Let's go with Kill Her first.
We'll kill her first and then we'll...
We'll live with her.
Please help me!
Dave, don't do this, please!
No!
Oh, I have to kill her!
Oh.
My butt.
Ah!
Oh no!
I'm sorry!
I was clicking too!
Wait, wait!
So sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, hold on.
Let me try that again.
Okay, kill.
Please help me!
Nice and slow.
Gentle clicks.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Wait, he's a wide man standing in the back!
Wow, that was neat.
Wow.
Welcome to our order, brother.
that was nice Oh no, he's not he's gonna be one of those serial killer hitchhiker guys.
Oh my god Where to
Where are you going?
Nowhere
What oh Oh my god
Why did it sound?
so sensual what are you doing saying playing harvester that thing I looked at it the other day the very thought breeding serial killers it's disgusting it's cool you'll rot your mind playing games like that don't you know people who watch violence become violent themselves oh no that's bullshit mom god my oh my god he's this is his mom's basement plays video games that make him roadrunner cartoon roadrunner cartoon roadrunner cartoon
roadrunner cartoon
Cannibalism!
Wait, I feel like we should have done that one last.
Roadrunner cartoons.
Roadrunner cartoons!
Cinematography.
Absolute cinema.
Oh no!
Oh my god!
This game was very in your face.
Response to the video games make you a killer hysteria of the 90s.
Even the skull and spinal cord thing is a direct reference to Mortal Kombat.
That's so cool!
Game over.
Okay.
I guess we do the good ending now, quote unquote, because this gives you a game over.
This ending is PM.
I like that ending so much.
Wow.
This is neat.
Okay, let's marry Stefan.
You disappoint me.
You had possibilities.
You died to become as twisted as you.
Your choice and succeeded in your quest.
Enjoy the life you've chosen.
Such as it is.
Why is he looked at- Oh my god, he marries us?
Hahaha!
Harvest properties
Wait, does the baby Is the baby also gonna...
Wait
Oh my god Oh my god What a waste This kid could have been something Never look back We got two more to plug in There's gotta be a better way to develop these serial killers This is scientific.
You want we should go back to the old way?
What old way?
Good breeding.
Ah,
I like the other ending way.
Way better.
The other ending was so much...
Let's watch it again.
The other ending was so good.
It still tells you game over.
Like you failed.
Makes me feel bad.
How come Steve gets to wear his clothes?
But Stephanie is in lingerie.
I don't know.
Roadrunner cartoons.
Please help me.
Oh,
please.
Yeah!
It's so crazy.
Wow.
That was neat.
Welcome to our order, brother.
Do you see his reflection?
The reflection above him makes me laugh so much.
He looks like big chungus.
Where are you?
going where are you going nowhere nowhere at all nowhere at all
vitality means phantom wins games are bad what are you doing
playing harvester playing harvester that's me right now i looked at it the other day the very thought breeding serial killers it's disgusting it's cool you'll rot your mind playing games like that don't you know people who watch violence become violent themselves that's bullshit mom it's no it isn't why do you think they started cutting the violence out of those roadrunner cartoons roadrunner cartoons Roadrunner cartoons.
Roadrunner cartoons.
This game is so...
Wow guys, we did it.
We beat Harvester.
That was so silly.
Roadrunner cartoons.
So funny.
I hope you guys liked it.
That was an experience.
And I'm glad that we could all experience together.
Thanks for the streaming, though.
Who knew the real terror would be the broken mechanics?
Well, once that was fixed, it was fine, but...
Mm-hmm.
Sorry.
I got tilted at that point.
But we made it through.
Thank you for streaming this weird, wonderful game.
I think wonderful is a strong word for this game, but it was definitely weird.
I did that fine, of course.
serial killer is born!
Me!
Easy toot!
Thank you so much for the 20!
Thank you!
Steve or Halligan?
Hmm.
Halligan?
I don't know.
I feel like the ending...
I feel like...
Steve was so normal now.
Thank you so much for the movie!
I feel like Steve was so normal.
And then if you choose the ending where he becomes a serial killer, It's so like out of pocket for him.
Yeah, he escalated like crazy.
It's fun to watch you play him in.
If you want another good point, click try.
I have no mouth and I must scream.
Oh, I've heard of that one before.
Yeah.
What watching Minto does to someone.
Crazy, crazy craziness.
I can't get over.
Roadrunner cartoons.
This game has a lot of common with MGS if you think about it.
Kind of, yeah.
I can't...
Get over Roadrunner cartoons.
Time to watch the rest of the cutscenes you missed out on.
Maybe another time.
Thank you for the experience of Harvester.
Thank you!
Man.
Confident of... No, stop recommending games.
You guys are weird.
But anyway, I have an hour until I have stuff that I gotta go do, so I'm gonna go off and eat some dinner.
It's surprising I still have an appetite after literally everything that happened, but...
It was fun!
It was fine, it was fine, it was fine.
This was something...
I went in with zero knowledge of what to expect at all.
And here we are.
Giant Robot Fan.
Thank you!
Gotta play any more Kirby games.
I don't know if soon, but I do plan on...
I do want to play more Kirby, yes.
Play Metal Gear Solid.
I feel like you might like it.
Hmm, Metal Gear.
Never heard of it.
Bet you could go for a burger right now.
I had a burger for lunch.
And I'll do it again.
No, I'm just kidding.
kidding.
Found this?
Anyway.
Thank you, guys.
Metal gear.
Oh, no.
Oh, my brain.
Wait, the thoughts.
S3 program.
Oh, okay.
It's starting to come back.
Oh, hell.
My heart.
Metal gear lives on through this arm.
Well, have you guys had fun?
Oh, we'll see you next time.
I'll see you when I see you.
you and yeah have a good day have a good night and have a good time for sure what's up it do bye bye bye bye bye bye